Band läuft.
Nice.
Kilian, do you think we should actually
switch to English now that we have 20
episodes and
broaden our audience
a little bit? So the next 20 are in English and then we'll
switch to Spanish?
The idea is that I learned Spanish
until then and then...
You've got 20 episodes time to learn Spanish.
Well, in our case that would
be roughly one and a half years.
I guess I could learn Spanish
in one and a half years.
Ich glaube, wir sprechen noch lieber Deutsch.
So this is episode 20 of acronymisable.
I think we just found a reason not to switch to English.
Schade. Ich finde die Titel auf Englisch sehr witzig.
Zumindest kann man es halt gut erzählen.
Wie heißt der Podcast? Ja, acronymisable.
Das bedeutet, das ist schwachste, die existente Wort.
Ist es acronymisable oder
acronymisable?
Ich würde aber sehr... Das acronym?
Das acronym?
Mizable.
Acronymanizable.
Geiles Wort.
Acronym...
Minizable.
Minizable?
Acronym...
Minizable.
Acronymizable.
Acronymizable? Acronymizable?
Liebe Zuhörer, wie würdet ihr unseren Namen auf Englisch hören?
Das wird tatsächlich überinteressant.
Okay, ja. Hi Kilian.
Hi Hendrik.
Wie geht's dir? Gut, und dir?
Ja, sehr gut. Ich hab gehört, du hast Prüfung.
Ja, stimmt. Ich revidiere mein Gut.
Aber in zwei Wochen geht's mir wieder gut.
Nee, alles ganz gut bisher.
Ich hab die nicht mal, noch nicht Halbzeit, aber bin grad mittendrin.
Ich bin ja so ein, ich weiß nicht, Langzeitstudent klingt so falsch, weil Langzeitstudent impliziert,
dass ich irgendwie in meinem einem Studium ewig drin hänge und irgendwann einfach nur noch so Semester...
Eher so der Studiengang-Hopper.
Ja, ich hänge irgendwie immer so
im Grundstudium. Das ist auch irgendwie falsch.
Aber jetzt bin ich ja nicht mehr
im Grundstudium. Ich bin tatsächlich nicht mehr im Grundstudium.
Ich habe es geschafft aus dem Grundstudium heraus.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Nach nur zwölf Semestern.
Offiziell
studiere ich aktuell.
Halte ich fest, Elektrotechnik und
Informationstechnik mit der Vertiefung Automatisierungstechnik
und Technische Informatik.
Abgefahren.
Ja. Ist witzig.
Was hat man da so?
Ja, so Kram wie halt
Elektrotechnik Basics zu
Regelungstechnik und Mikroprozessortechnik
und solche Dinge.
Das heißt, du wirst irgendwann mal
jetzt hängst du
den Softwareentwicklertraum
an den Haken und wirst irgendwann
Chipentwickler? Nein.
Nicht? Nein.
Elektriker? Nein.
Nein, ich will
irgendwas Softwareentwicklung richtig machen.
Aber es ist tatsächlich recht spannend, mal so ein bisschen
seinen Kontext
oder seinen Horizont zu erweitern.
Das ist ja was, was mir total fehlt.
Also ich habe jetzt in letzter Zeit
angefangen, mir den YouTube-Channel
von Simone Geerts anzugucken,
die hier Shitty Robots baut.
Die sind so cool.
Und
die schrauben halt mal irgendwas zusammen
und programmierst so ein Arduino und
das Ding dann irgendwas machen.
selbst so ein paar
Widerstände zusammenlöten
oder sowas, habe ich nie gemacht.
Das müsste ich jetzt irgendwie mal von vorne lernen, wenn ich sowas
machen möchte. Mein längerfristigeres Projekt,
mir so einen Snips-AI-basierten
Home Assistant
zu bauen, der irgendwie noch so ein bisschen Zeugs drum
rum hat, das
hängt so ein bisschen davon ab eigentlich.
Ich muss sagen, so wirklich sicher
auf der Schiene fühle ich mich jetzt auch noch nicht.
Ich habe da schon, also löten kann ich
zum einen, aber was
genau und wie ich Dinge zusammen löte,
die Welt hat sich mir noch nie so ganz erschlossen.
Und gerade wenn man so, keine Ahnung,
online irgendwelche Projekte durchschaut
und dann da so merkt, ja hier,
da steckst du das und das und das zusammen und dann läuft das.
Ja, warum stecke ich denn diese Dinge so zusammen?
Genau, warum muss ich denn,
wenn ich mir eine LED kaufe und so
ein Breadboard und das offen,
die Leute werden uns jetzt auslachen, aber mich jetzt so auslachen,
wenn ich mir so ein Breadboard kaufe und so ein LED,
warum brauche ich denn jetzt ausgerechnet diese
Vorwiderstände um mit die LED?
Für die LEDs brauchst du die gar nicht mehr.
Nee, ist schon die Fidelity schon.
Aber die Union sind die oftmals schon mehr drauf.
Also ich glaube, ich muss mal zu irgendeinem Makerspace gehen
und so einen Anfängerkurs hier.
Ich bastel mir was auf so einem Breadboard mitmachen,
den irgendwie bei den Datenspuren schon die Sechsjährigen mitmachen.
Das bräuchte ich, auf dem Level bin ich selbst noch gar nicht.
Aber ja, cool.
Same hier und ich studiere das jetzt beide.
Traurig.
Das hoffentlich wird das niemand, der mich kennt.
Und an was hackst du gerade so?
Ich habe tatsächlich gerade alles dank Prüfung aufgeschoben.
Normalerweise ist in der Prüfungszeit immer die produktive Zeit,
wo ich mich an allen möglichen Side-Projects versuche,
weil man ja da viel Motivation hat, alles zu tun
und die Wohnung ist immer am saubersten, klassischerweise.
Deswegen hast du auch schon den dritten Studiengang in Folge?
Exakt, genau.
Diesmal habe ich es tatsächlich geschafft, alles aufzuschieben.
Aber tatsächlich wurde mir auch letztens
mein eine Side-Project ein bisschen kaputt gemacht.
Kaputt gemacht?
Ja, ich habe doch an einer witzigen App für ÖPNV-Datengeld gearbeitet und wollte mal was rausbringen.
Und bin aber letztens über eine gestolpert, die einfach in jeder Hinsicht tausendmal besser ist.
Welche?
Die heißt ÖPNV-Navigator.
Die gibt es für iOS.
Die ist große Klasse.
Kann ich wärmstens empfehlen, allen, die zuhören.
Und unterstützt auch nicht nur den regionalen VVO hier, also den VVO, den Verkehrsbrunnen Oberelbe,
sondern viele andere Sachen, unter anderem auch ganz allgemein einfach die Deutsche Bahn.
Und die haben ja quasi für alle regionalen Anbieter in Deutschland was.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es außerhalb von Deutschland aussieht,
aber das ist jetzt nicht so mein Alltags-Use-Case.
Auf jeden Fall, tolle App, kann wirklich quasi, wie gesagt, alles.
Hat ein tolles Widget für iOS, hat sogar eine Apple Watch-App, ist alles vertreten.
Darauf willkommen bin ich, wegen eines witzigen Fuck-Ups von Google.
Und zwar haben die Befi aus dem Play Store geworfen.
Ist das immer noch so?
Das wurde mittlerweile, soweit ich weiß,
begründet von Seiten Google.
Der Witz war ja. Andreas Schildbach,
der Entwickler von Öffi, hatte
online gepostet, dass Öffi aus dem Store ist.
Und Google hatte dafür
eine Begründung geschickt, nämlich
eine sehr lange Begründung und die
leitet im Wortlaut Payments.
Das war es.
Sehr eloquent.
Sehr eloquent, ja.
Mittlerweile hatten sie es ein bisschen besser begründet und zwar
ist es für Google nicht okay, dass
eine entscheidende Free-App im Playstore
ist, die aber auch
Alternativvarianten, also von der es
Alternativvarianten gibt im Afterworld
oder auf der Entwicklerwebsite
direkt und da kann man spenden. Nicht in der
Playstore-Variante, in der anderen.
Aber weil die existiert, ist es
ja quasi wie die Playstore-Variante mit Spenden,
das ja untersagt, deswegen, nö, ist nicht.
Weil man nicht spenden können soll,
oder wie? Genau, du sollst nicht an Google
vorbei spenden können, weil da verdient Google ja nichts.
Ah,
Aber es gibt noch, das habe ich ja eigentlich schon
vorher gesehen, dass es irgendwie die Variante...
Ach nee, viele machen das so, dass die Variante
im Play Store Geld kostet
und dann gibt es irgendwie über
F-Droid eine kostenlose Variante.
Das ist eine Option, was viele in der iOS-Welt
machen, ist generell eine kostenlose App.
Und du hast einen Spenden-Button in der App
und du zahlst per
In-App-Purchase, das heißt 30% gehen an Apple,
70% an den Entwickler.
Und das ist wieder okay. Und das finde ich
auch tatsächlich für mich mit die angenehmste
Variante. Das ist aber schon ein ganz schöner
Wegzoll, den sie sich da ausnehmen.
Natürlich, gar keine Frage.
Absolut. Offiziell darfst du halt in der App
keine, du darfst kein Geld annehmen, ohne dass
es halt über Apple geht.
Da gibt es keinen Weg vorbei.
Und machen manche und die werden halt irgendwann aus dem
So rausgekickt, wenn das halt offensichtlich
wird. Ich meine, das App Review klappt ja auch
unfehlbar 100% der Zeit immer ganz
gut. Hier, wink, wink.
Aber es ist halt
nicht erlaubt. Du darfst halt genauso wie bei Google
offiziell, wenn du eine App im Store hast,
Zahlungen nur über den
den Standard-Payment-Weg, der ja eher eingebaut ist,
gehen. Und ja,
also für mich als Nutzer ist es okay.
Und ich habe auch gerade bei der App ÖPNV-Navigator
ist es so, du kannst in den Einstellungen
dem Entwickler spenden. Der hat fünf Kategorien da, glaube ich.
Und du kannst halt den aussuchen. Ich habe auch einmal
eine angeklickt. Finde ich auch in der Schützungsfette-App.
Der ÖPNV-Navigator sieht das nicht
sonderlich anders als Öffi.
Das Icon ist das gleiche, aber das ist ja
auch dieses allgemeine Fahrhaltestellen-Symbol.
Ansonsten habe ich
Öffi schon lange nicht mehr gewusst. Die Ansicht ist aber
sehr ähnlich, gerade mit den,
dass du die, so einen Strang siehst
mit so einem Balkendiagramm
mäßig, wo du halt so von der Seite
scrollen kannst und die angezeigt werden,
wie lang meine Teilfahrten
sind und verschiedene Farbblöcke,
wo du umsteigen musst und so weiter.
Die Ansicht ist, glaube ich, von Ophelia Inspirator.
Ich weiß auch nicht, ob die Ophelia erfunden hat.
Das ist einfach diese Gantt-Diagramm-Ansicht,
dass du irgendwie siehst, von wann du das
lässt sich, da gibt es glaube ich nicht so viele Alternativen zu.
So ein vertikales Haltestellen-Gantt-Diagramm.
Das beschreibt wahrscheinlich ganz,
wahrscheinlich gibt es einen perfekten Begriff dafür.
aber den kennen wir jetzt leider nicht.
Ja, so ein Time
Table
Balken
Genau.
Sag keinem, dass ich Medieninformatik studiert habe.
Hast du mit Informationsvisualisierung
irgendwas am Hut?
Ich habe das teilweise belegt, ja.
Aber auch nur, weil ich in dem Bereich Medieninformatik
unbedingt noch irgendwas brauchte.
Verstehe.
Dann habe ich eigentlich ein sehr
unmedieninformatikmäßiges
Medieninformatikstudium
abgelegt.
Ja, mir ist das bloß irgendwie aufgefallen, weil
weil Öffi,
als ich es mal aufgemacht habe, tatsächlich gesagt habe,
wir sind jetzt aus dem...
Irgendwie haben sie es geschafft, hier so eine Meldung
einzublenden. Achso, ja, genau. Öffi benutze
ich leider so selten, dass jedes Mal, wenn ich es aufmache,
ich irgendwie diesen riesen Change-Log
wegklicken muss, wo
irgendwas steht, was mich überhaupt nicht interessiert.
Aber nee, stimmt. Vorher habe ich sogar auf Deutschlandfunk
Nova davon gehört, dass Öffi jetzt
gebannt wurde. Das war denen irgendwie
fünf Minuten Beitrag wert.
Okay.
Ja, aber Öffi hat ja, also das eine
coole Feature von Öffi, also was heißt das
eine coole Feature, das ist eine klasse App, gar keine Frage,
ist, dass der Andreas Schildbach, ja,
also diese ganze Library, die Öffi nutzt,
die Public Transport Enabler heißt das Ding,
dass es Open Source ist, das ist eine
ziemlich dicke Java-Bibliothek,
also ziemlich dick jetzt vom Source her zumindest,
ich weiß nicht, wie ich das tatsächlich jetzt hier irgendwie
bei hier Bedürfnisse oder Rahmenverbrauch angehe,
keine Ahnung, aber ich habe es jetzt nur, weil
es halt
API-Wrapper für wirklich
diverse ÖPNV-Anbieter weltweit anbietet.
Und da ist wirklich alles drin.
Und das finde ich echt ein sehr angenehm, schickes Ding.
Und das ist ja das, was ich länger mal...
Das ist mein Langzeitprojekt,
was ich immer noch nicht angefangen habe,
aber im Kopf rumgeistert seit Jahren schon.
Das mal nach Swift supporten.
Das nach Rust supporten.
Und dann halt eine C-Library...
Stimmt, das hast du schon mal erzählt.
Eine C-AP, genau, dass man da halt auf alles rausgehen kann.
Das wäre so schön.
Das ist immer noch so ein Traum von mir.
Aber das musste halt natürlich...
Auf der einen Seite ist es halt
eine API eher, auf der anderen
Seite
bist du ja selber dein Client an
35.000 unterschiedliche Endpoints,
die eventuell, manche sind wahrscheinlich
gescraped sogar, manche haben
vielleicht richtige APIs.
Da bist du wahrscheinlich ganz schön im Hinterherrennen die ganze Zeit.
Da musst du eine gute
Integration Suite haben, die irgendwie
die Regelmäßig sagen können, ach jetzt hier in Zürich
ist es kaputt gegangen oder jetzt in
Bernburg fährt jetzt der Bus
anders oder wird nichts mehr angezeigt.
oder sowas. Was jetzt explizit PTE,
also dieses Public Transport Enabler angeht,
die haben jetzt zum Beispiel nicht, insofern ich zumindest
weiß, was scraped oder so weiter, also wirklich
dreckige Daten reinzieht, sondern die haben
insofern nicht, also wie gesagt,
ich bin mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher, könnte sehr
gefährliches Halbwissen sein, da drei oder
vier verschiedene APIs, die halt sehr verbreitet
sind, die sie rappen und da halt dann
für die einzelnen Provider,
natürlich geht ja trotzdem vieles kaputt, weil die halt ihre APIs
umziehen oder keine Ahnung, sonst was für
Fehler werfen oder alles
Mögliche, aber man muss zumindest nicht
ganz so dreckig sein. Und die viele
Schnittstellen, die existieren, sei es dieses
EFA, also diese elektronische
Fahrplanauskunft heißt das, glaube ich,
oder alles andere, was der VDV
verbricht, dieser Bund Deutscher Verkehrsbetriebe,
dieses Trias, dieses neue,
oder Haffas,
wie heißt es die von, ah, von Harkon, Haffas,
genau, das sind schon recht verbreitete
Dinge, die werden auch echt weltweit
genutzt und da kann man schon recht viel machen,
wenn man nur darüber geht.
Und das wäre halt ein guter Ansatz
auf jeden Fall. Gab es nicht irgendwie eine
standardisierte API oder einen Wunsch, eine standardisierte
API für zum Beispiel DVB
einzuführen? Oder ging es dabei nur
um allgemeine Fahrplandaten
und nicht über aktuelle Abfahrtszahlen?
Es gibt halt, wie gesagt, etliche Standards, unter anderem
auch GTFS für diverse Daten.
Etliche Standards ist ja das ein Problem.
Das ist ja das Schöne an Standards.
Es gibt ja so viele davon.
Was halt der VDV, also wie gesagt,
dieser Verein Deutscher Verkehrsbetriebe,
macht
von vielen Leuten wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen unfair, aber wahrscheinlich auch größtenteils fair bezeichnete
Saftladen.
Verbrochen hat jetzt wieder diese neue
Schnittstelle, dieses Trias oder
das hat irgendein anderer Namen noch, dieses unglaublich
komplexe API, was
jetzt alle unterstützen können sollten,
also irgendwann mal.
Der VVO hat schon
eine Instanz hier dafür, wo halt
sehr wenige Teile davon wirklich
implementiert sind und da kannst du halt wirklich alles
drüber machen. Da geht halt jetzt natürlich
der klassische Departure Monitor im Sinne von, hier ist eine
Haltestelle, gib mir bitte alles, was da fährt
Oder ich würde eine Route von A nach B.
Oder ich, keine Ahnung, suche irgendwas.
Oder da gibt es halt sogar eine Option drin,
dass man halt elektronisch über einen API-Endpoint
den Stop-Button in einem Bus drücken kann.
Ach so.
Und die Idee dafür ist halt,
dass deine App zum Beispiel weiß, wo du fährst.
Das weiß, dass du jeden Tag die Route von A nach B fährst zur Arbeit.
Und dann gehst du halt nur in den Bus rein
und die App sieht halt im Hintergrund per GPS,
du bist in dem Bus,
sieht vielleicht auch das Netzwerk in dem Bus,
dass du da gerade wirklich physisch vorhanden bist,
dass du physisch wirklich in dem Bus bist.
Und drück dann für dich den Stop-Button,
dass du gar nicht selber auf den Button drücken musst.
Das wäre halt der eine Use-Case.
Der andere Use-Case ist, oder hinten kommt mein Bus
an der Haltestelle schnell noch in der App den Stop-Button hämmern,
dass der auch Ja anhält, dass du noch ein bisschen kannst.
Das ist alles, was mir dazu einfällt.
Ja, da gibt es wahrscheinlich noch einiges mehr.
Du könntest, wenn du damit noch dein Ticket abdeckst,
sagen, checken, oh, hier in diesem Bus sitzen drei Schwarzfahrer,
weil deren Handys haben sie es nicht eingeloggt.
Und dann wird es schon wieder fast ein bisschen gruselig.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall ein Video,
von was das mal alles zeigt,
diese Patriots-Features.
Das finde ich sehr witzig, weil es unter anderem
mit an der TU Dresden hier entwickelt wurde.
Du kennst auch ein paar Leute, die an dem Projekt
beteiligt waren. Das Witzige ist
dieses Video,
das zeigt am Beispiel der
DVB viele dieser Trias-Features,
aber die Daten,
die sie halt zeigen in dem Video,
sind glaube ich aus Stuttgart oder so. Das heißt,
du siehst so jemand, ich navigiere von da
nach da in Stuttgart und dann kommt so eine
Bahn von so einer Achtrichtung, keine Ahnung,
wie in Dresden hier von der DVB angefangen, steigt ein Postplatz
ein so. Nein, das ist nicht das, was da gerade steht.
Ich weiß, dass das nicht das ist.
Das ist so eine leichte kognitive Dissonanz.
Ja, das ist so probiert.
Ich suche es gerade.
Können wir auch noch kurz unterbrechen?
Dann suche ich da wirklich raus.
Trias, VDV.
Dann machen wir das mal kurz. Ich drücke mal kurz auf Pause.
Baus, irgendwas. Google.
Ja, zeig mal her.
Oh, das ist nicht das Video, oder?
Das ist hier nicht mehr DVB.
Halt schon zur anregende Musik.
Springen wir ein bisschen
nach vorne rein
Doch, da, da, da
Hier ist ja ein anderer Slup
Ein bisschen die Musik leise
Ja, kommt auf jeden Fall in die Schaulose, das Video
Genau, hier
Fahrt zur Straßenbahnwelt, kennst du einen Ort in Dresden
der Straßenbahnwelt heißt? Ich nicht
Vielleicht ist das
bangwas im Verkehrsmuseum
Aber das Geile ist, sie
routet jetzt gleich
Ich
Es lässt, dass Leute da rauskommen aus diesem
Dead-Enter
Aha
Hier, sie ist eindeutig an der
Haltestelle Prager Straße, öffnet in Google Maps
Marienplatz
Sonst wo? Sie ist jetzt sowieso irgendwie
von der Slub in die Altstadt
gebeamt worden. Ja, sowieso. Und jetzt fährt sie
zur Straßenbahnwelt in Stuttgart, genau.
Und natürlich
kommt die Bahn hier vorne gleich,
die nach Stuttgart fährt,
an der Prager Straße. Das hätte ich manchmal gerne.
Oh, schau.
Hier ist eine U-Bahn. Hier ist nicht bei der Nähe.
Wahrscheinlich hat sie sich da hingestellt, damit man
diesen komischen Gulli-Eingang für eine U-Bahn hält.
Das ist das Einzige, in Dresden, was aussieht wie eine U-Bahn
an der alten Stelle ist. Geht sie da jetzt rein?
Das wäre super witzig.
Das erinnert mich an dieses
Image-Video von der Fakultät Informatik.
wo Leute vor der E023
in der Fakultät stehen und
die Kamera pannt so vor der E023,
Leute gehen rein und dann Schnitt
und dann siehst du eine Vorlesung im HSZ E03.
Das ist nicht
das Richtige.
Aber das weiß man halt nicht,
wenn man sowas schaut.
Du hast gerade irgendwie schon ein bisschen ein Thema angeteasert,
das ich gerne mal,
da kennst du dich wahrscheinlich besser aus als ich,
so Regeln,
die man einhalten muss, wenn man
im App Store sein möchte und da nicht rausfliegen möchte.
Ja, ist halt
sehr wandelbar. Also erinnert sich
vieles über die Zeit.
Und gibt auch etliche Regeln. Ich kenne mich nicht so wirklich
mit den Google Play Store Regeln. Also ich hätte das wahrscheinlich das Thema
vorhin ansprechen sollten, als wir gerade mitten dabei waren.
Aber dann sind wir so zu
Öffi rüber gedriftet.
Also Öffi ist jetzt rausgeflogen oder
jetzt wieder reingekommen? Noch nicht,
soweit ich weiß. Weil sie
irgendwie ein alternatives
Payment-Konzept hatten, was
Google nicht gefallen hat. Sowas ähnliches gibt es ja
bei Apple auch,
dass du irgendwie, ach ja genau, ich war auf der Output,
das ist ja
diese Messe, diese fakultätsinterne
Messe an der Informatikfakultät in Dresden
und
da hat ein Bekanter von uns
ja auch diese Output-App gemacht,
wo du irgendwie an einem
Gewinnspiel teilnehmen konntest und die du dich irgendwie so über die
Output navigieren lassen konntest und für die
iOS-Nutzer musstest du dir das halt
am Eingang von denen auf dem Laptop
mit einem Lightning-Kabel direkt aufs
Phone flashen lassen, weil sie es nicht in den App-Store
geschafft haben.
Wegen Gambling-Regeln.
Weil da halt ein Gewinnspiel mit dabei war.
Und
an dem gleichen Tag
war noch irgendwo ein Stand
von einer anderen Gruppe, die hatten die iDrone
vorgestellt. Hast du diese iDrone-Geschichte
mitbekommen? Ich habe es mitbekommen.
Das Prinzip, ich habe was viel
cooleres erwartet als das, was es da ist.
Ich erzähle mal kurz, worum es geht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die eine Web-Präsenz haben,
aber die standen zumindest auf der Output rum und haben diese App da
angepriesen.
Und das war,
das hatten,
sie hatten so ein geiles Imagevideo gedreht
und im Endeffekt,
hatten sie erklärt,
naja, du möchtest ja,
eigentlich möchtest du ja
eine Drone haben,
eine Drohne haben,
um irgendwie so Luftaufnahmen
machen zu können, so.
Aber das Problem mit so einer Drohne
ist, die ist schwer
und teuer und groß
und dann fliegt die halt
durch die Gegend,
dann darfst du an manchen Stellen
nicht fliegen
und eigentlich alles,
was du da drin hast,
so eine Kamera oder so,
hast du ja in deinem Smartphone
auch schon.
Ergo,
die iDrone.
Und dann haben sie quasi
eine App gebaut,
die gab es aber nur für Android.
Wenn du die gestartet hast
und dein Telefon hochgeworfen hast, hat es
am höchsten Punkt ein Foto gemacht.
Wer weiß, wer das ist? Achso, wenn die man
vor... Der ist ein Max-Anhandelsbeschleunigungssensor,
wenn der irgendwie gerade wieder kippt,
dann fällt es da glaube ich
gerade wieder runter und dann war es am höchsten Punkt.
Und ich hatte mir das installiert und es hat tatsächlich
ich hatte irgendwie drei, vier, fünf Fotos
mich getraut zu machen mit meinem Telefon.
Ich kann aber auch, ich meine, ich kann auch mit
vier Bällen jonglieren, ich kann gut Sachen fangen.
Und
ein Foto war einigermaßen
nicht ganz super unscharf und
wackel. Aber ich glaube,
das ist eine Technik, die könnte man üben.
Die haben zumindest erzählt, dass sie die App nicht
in den App Store gekriegt haben.
Da gibt es explizit eine Regel dagegen.
Und die lautet? Apps, die halt
promoten, dass du dein Device in Gefahr
bringst oder explizit kaputt machst, sind halt
nicht zugelassen.
Der eine Fall, der mir noch einfällt, war
einmal so ein Handy-Weitwurf-Spiel.
Und das ist quasi dieselbe
Idee, bloß ein Handy-Hochwurf-Spiel
in dem Fall dieses Eye-Drown-Dings ist.
Und das andere war ein Taschenwärmer
in App-Form, der einfach deine CPU
so hart gestresst hat, dass du halt im Winter deine Hände
am Handy wärmen konntest. Die Idee ist
witzig, die Umsetzung halt nur
also auch witzig,
aber technisch doof, in dem Sinne,
dass du halt wirklich dein Gerät kaputt machst auf Dauer,
wenn du das als unwissendem Nutzer ständig nutzt.
Naja, ich meine, du wirst
irgendwann, hast du ein Incentive, es nicht mehr zu benutzen,
weil halt dein Akku ständig runter ist, ne?
Ja, vielleicht merkst du das ja nicht. Vielleicht bist du der Meinung,
hey, ich nutze diese App hier, die macht einfach mein Handy
warm und jetzt ist mein Akkumarsch und ihr seid
schuld, Apple.
Ja, gut, okay, also die Erklärung möchte ich dann auch
nicht abgeben müssen, warum das nicht geht.
Ja, also
es gibt halt, wie gesagt, diese Regel, du darfst
nicht aktiv Geräte zerstören.
Handyweidwurf. Ja, das gab's mal,
ja, war halt auch so eine Sache.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie das
gemacht wurde. Ich hatte das ein paar Mal
ausprobiert und hatte auch die Fotos dann
vertwittert mit dem Hashtag iDrown,
die haben mich sehr darüber gefreut und
danach hatte ich dann aber auch das Interesse
dann nochmal wieder daran verloren.
Es war halt hauptsächlich auf der Output schön,
weil wir da halt, die machen sie seit zwei Jahren
im Innenhof der Informatik und nicht nebenan
nur auf dem Parkplatz dort.
Also diese Summer Party
danach, da war halt
jahrelang vorher auf dem Parkplatz
daneben, hatten sie eine Bühne aufgebaut und haben ein paar Bands
spielen lassen und eigentlich
hat die Fakultät ja diesen wunderschönen Innenhof,
ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch daran erinnert,
wir hatten Folge
6, 7, hatten wir
Freien im Innenhof der Fakultät aufgenommen.
Ich hatte mir sogar ein Foto, dann nachträglich vertortet,
weil wir es in der Folge vergessen haben.
Genau, und jetzt irgendwie
vor zwei Jahren haben sie angefangen, haben einfach diese
Party danach im Innenhof gemacht, dann steht
da ein DJ mit, ein paar Boxen macht, ein bisschen Hausmusik,
eigentlich viel geiler, und dann sitzen die Leute da
am Teich und auf der Wiese und
es ist irgendwie viel geselliger, als dass man sich da irgendwie
auf den Parkplatz hoppen muss.
Ich weiß auch nicht, warum so viele Freienstellungen in den Parkplatz
gelegt werden, das ist sehr eigenartig.
Ja, wenn ihr irgendwie eine Bühne aufbauen möchtet,
das wäre da hinten nicht gegangen, aber auf der anderen Seite
Bühne hat auch nicht zu
Gesprächen eingeladen. Da standest du halt
vor der Bühne und hast so ein bisschen gerockt, aber...
Ist halt so viel angenehmer beim Teich.
So kommen
besser Gespräche zustande.
Es gibt übrigens, wenn wir gerade schon mal in App Store Regeln waren,
eine tolle Seite, die heißt appstorereviewguidelineshistory.com
als ein langer Schwert.
Und die nehmen immer,
gerade wenn Apple Änderungen an den App Store Review
Guidelines veröffentlicht, die
posten die vor einem zum einen
und zum anderen machen die halt einen schönen Diff davon
und zeigen dir halt, was die Unterschiede sind,
damit du es schnell überfliegen kannst.
Das ist sehr angenehm.
Und da kann man auch wirklich mal durchscrollen und schauen.
Ich dachte jetzt, es wäre so eine Liste von Precedences,
von Apps, die es nicht in den App Store geschafft haben,
aus den und den Gründen.
Das wäre mal witzig.
Es gibt immer wieder viele dumme Umsetzungen der Gründe,
vor allem, weil halt zum Beispiel in den App Store Guidelines,
wie viele Gestalt Guidelines steht halt,
seit Anbeginn des App Stores 2008 steht drin,
das war wahrscheinlich nicht an Anbeginn,
weil da gab es glaube ich noch keine Pushen oder Verkehrchen,
aber seit Anbeginn des App-Stores als Push-Notifications gab,
steht drin, dass du keine Push-Notifications
zu Marketingzwecken versenden darfst.
Und diese Regel bricht einfach jeder inklusive Apple selber.
Es wäre so schön, wenn die mal umgesetzt werden würde.
Und es gibt halt auch diverse Firmen,
die halt wirklich offen damit umgehen,
dass sie diverse Features vor Apple verstecken im Review.
Uber hat das ja teilweise sogar so witzig gemacht,
dass sie es einfach am GPS-Standpunkt des Reviewers festgemacht haben,
weil Apple halt so doof ist und testet die Apps
halt mit der physischen
Location Cupertino, ob die jetzt auf wie viele
Geräten GPS faken, keine Ahnung,
oder das im Simulator.
Das wäre absolut legitim
und würde auch viel sinnvoller sein, weil da kann man
auch andere Edge Cases mit abdecken,
aber Uber hat es ja explizit daran
festgemacht, dass es, wenn es in
Cupertino getestet wird, dann hast du halt bestimmte Features nicht gesehen
und ich weiß auch von anderen Firmen,
die ARM-App-Mitarbeiter, die ganzen Features,
auf diese verzichten müssen.
Oder andere Firmen, die halt wirklich
Features verstecken, solange die App im Review ist
und dann halt natürlich, sobald die App im Store ist,
wird halt ein Flag-Server-seitig gesetzt
und dann werden die Features-enabled-App-seitig.
Du kannst halt überhaupt nichts verhindern von Seiten Apple aus,
wie willst du das auch machen,
außer die Firmen im Nachhinein abstrafen.
Aber das kannst du halt auch nur bedingt im Falle von Uber.
Die kannst du halt, also da ist es halt medial ein bisschen witzig gewesen,
weil da sich wohl Tim Cook mit Uber getroffen hat
und den wohl so ein bisschen auf die Finger gehauen hat.
Aber das geht halt auch nur bei,
also Uber ist schon zu groß,
um sie aus dem App Store zu kicken. Da würden sich
Kunden darüber beschweren, die die App nutzen
und dann keine iPhones kaufen. Das ist auch der Grund,
warum für die ganz großen
Apps wie Facebook und Twitter und so weiter
diverse explizite Ausnahmen
in UIKit,
in Apples
UI-IOS-Framework
eingebaut sind, die um diverse Bugs und Crashes
in diesen Apps herumarbeiten,
weil es Apple halt
zu teuer wird, wenn diese Apps
Probleme haben und die von den
jeweiligen Entwicklern selber gefixt werden müssen.
Das muss halt auf der Plattform laufen. Das ist halt echt schade
eigentlich. Hatten wir das nicht schon mal thematisiert
zufällig, das Thema? Ich glaube schon.
Ich weiß, dass bei uns im Firmen-Slack mal rumging.
Ach ja, stimmt. Das MacOS haben wir gesagt. Das hattest du mal
irgendwie gepostet oder so. Ja, ich erinnere mich.
Diese 200 Apps waren,
der Blogpost hieß es wortwörtlich,
diese 200 Apps sind so buggy, dass
Apple sie in
was? Das war MacOS dann.
In MacOS in AppKit oder
fixen musste.
Und dann war irgendwie
auch die Anwendung meiner Firma
mit dabei und dann wurde intern mal ein bisschen diskutiert
und mal geschaut, was sie so gemacht haben. Das ist auch aufgezählt
gewesen. Das waren halt ganz
kleine Anpassungen, die sie da gemacht haben.
Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass Apple
innerhalb ihrer
Standard-Library
war das jetzt Foundation
oder ich weiß nicht mehr genau,
zur Laufzeit prüft, welche Anwendung
gerade läuft und dann quasi intern das Verhalten
von ihrer Library leicht ändern. Das ist natürlich dann
super creepy, wenn du als Entwickler an so einem
Projekt arbeitest, irgendwann mitkriegst,
da ist Verhalten, was vom Standardverhalten
abweicht, aber nur für dieses Projekt.
Wie geht man mit sowas um? Ich habe
keine Ahnung.
Also die
genauen Details davon, vielleicht können wir
den einfach nochmal verlinken. Es war alles nichts
superkritisches. Es hat auch nichts
wirklich das Verhalten verändert.
Aber es waren leichte Anpassungen, die App irgendwie gemacht haben
und alle haben irgendwie zum Schluss sogar gesagt, ja, aber eigentlich
ist das alles nicht so tragisch gewesen.
Es haben ja viele auch diesen Blogpost
kritisiert, weil der es so dargestellt
hätte, als wären diese ganzen Apps alle
buggy gewesen ist. Und das war
einfach nicht der Fall. Das waren leichte
Bugs.
UIKit hat wohl noch viel, viel mehr
diese Ausnahmen. Also wirklich, ich meine, vielfach
ist mehr. Das finde ich schon interessant.
Das ist auch nach dem Motto, mein UIKit ist nicht gleich dein
UIKit. Ja, vor allem, stell mal vor, du arbeitest an
UIKit. Wie schrecklich muss es bitte sein, so die Codebase
zu maintainen, wenn da halt noch zigtausende Ausnahmen an jeder
Ecke definiert sind. Du musst für jeden Benutzer
irgendwie so einen Fleck mit einbauen.
Ja, nee, das geht eigentlich nicht. Ach, ich habe jetzt
noch nicht was Schönes gesehen. Was war das?
zum Thema Flex, du kannst ja
in Programmier-Sprachen auch so Compile-Flex setzen.
Ich mache das ja auch. Bei Rust-Projekten
kannst du ja so Features setzen und bei
SIFT gibt es sowas bestimmt auch. Bei
C und C++ gibt es so Pragmas
und gewisse Makros, die du
machen kannst. Und ich habe jetzt neulich was gesehen, wie man
C99 von
C90 unterscheiden kann.
Okay. Das ist ja auch mir auf Twitter
vorbeigescrollt, das muss ich mal nachsuchen.
Und zwar hat C90
noch keine Doppel-Slash
Kommentare unterstützt.
Oh Gott, dann machst du es über Kommentare.
Und da hat er irgendwie eine Variante
angelegt, ist gleich gemacht, da irgendeine Zahl
reingeschrieben und dann
bestimmte Slash, Sternchen, Sternchen,
Slash, Slash, Slash irgendwie und dann irgendwie eine andere
Zahl reingeschrieben und dann hat er hinterher ein
If-State gemacht und je nachdem, welcher
Wert da drin stand, konnte er sagen, das wurde jetzt mit
1090 und mit 1099er Standard
geordnet. Oh, wie dreckig.
Achso, das war glaube ich die Reaktion auf den schönen Tweet.
Genauso wie der
Und-Und-Operator und der
Pipe-Pipe, also der
Oder-Operator, optimiert sind,
die rechte Seite des Operators nicht zu
evaluieren. Genau das macht auch der
Slash-Slash-Operator.
Hab ich auch gelesen.
Und da stand es, glaube ich, unten drunter.
Ich weiß nicht, sogar ein Tweet von Joe Groff,
dem einen bei Ernst Zwift
arbeiten, der ist so ein Troller auf Twitter,
dieser Typ, der postet sich die ganze Zeit nur zurück.
Das hat zumindest sehr viel Spaß gemacht.
Oder hat zumindest retweetet und deswegen
in meiner Timeline gelandet.
Nee, das war
Shaki
Jaguar, keine Ahnung.
Ah, okay, dann hat er es nur retweetet gehabt.
Doch, es war eine Reaktion auf
Joe Groff.
Like and and and pipe pipe
which avoid evaluating the right hand side
so does the slash slash operator.
Und hier dieses Stück C
kurz sieht halt irgendwie so aus.
Ich poste es mal in die Show Notes.
Oh Gott.
Klar, so kann man natürlich sowas machen.
Das ist halt so schrecklich.
Ja.
Und genauso ist dann wahrscheinlich jetzt die
Apple Foundation
Codepase voll von solchen Checklist.
Also Foundation betrifft das soweit ich weiß nicht,
aber natürlich ist Foundation auch nicht Open Source, beziehungsweise es gibt ja eine
Open Source Variante von Foundation, die zusammen mit
Swift jetzt entwickelt wird, aber das ist halt nicht gleich
Foundation. Das ist das Foundation, was du kriegst, wenn du
auf Linux... Oder AppKit.
Ja, genau, ich schaffte die schon ab in der anderen Thematik.
Auf jeden Fall, was das AppKit und UIKit betreffend.
Genau.
gefahren. Super witzig.
Wo wir gerade bei UIs sind,
ich habe jetzt auch tatsächlich mal wieder eine kleine UI
gebastelt. Ah, cool.
Auf welcher Basis?
JavaScript.
Ja, es ist überhaupt nicht mein Dings, aber ich verdiene
ja mein Geld mit TypeScript und JavaScript und ich bin
eigentlich offiziell Webentwickler.
Und wir haben für unsere
Libs, die wir auf Arbeit, für unsere
eigentliche App bauen, haben wir halt so Testseiten.
Und da wechseln wir zum Spaß immer mal
das Framework. Das heißt, die eine
Testseite ist in React gebaut, die andere ist
Angular gebaut,
die neueste, die wir jetzt für
was anderes gebaut haben oder so für kleine
Oberflächen,
so Tooling-Oberflächen, nehmen wir halt immer mal was anderes,
da hat jetzt ein Kollege
Angular genommen
und ich hatte mich bis vor zwei Jahren überhaupt
nicht mit solchen Frameworks auseinandergesetzt
und hab jetzt mal in Vue reingeguckt, als der das gezeigt hat.
Vue hat er ja diesmal genommen
und vorher war was anderes Angular, genau.
Und genau,
Vue und
was ich mir jetzt angeguckt hatte, war Svelte.
Davon hatten schon andere
Leute mal irgendwie erzählt und geschwärmt,
was eigentlich ganz cool ist.
Was diesen ganzen Frameworks, wie ich das jetzt
mitbekommen habe, eigentlich gemeinsam ist, ist, dass
die halt alle versuchen
und bitte schreibt
uns auf Twitter, schreibt mir auf Twitter,
wie weit ich jetzt da neben liege,
dass die eigentlich versuchen, Rendering
und View einigermaßen, Rendering
und State zu trennen und du baust quasi
einzelne Komponenten,
UI-Komponenten, die quasi, die du
verwenden kannst wie HTML-Tags,
die aus dem
HTML-Tags,
das ist bei React ganz
typisch so, du baust halt eine Komponente,
da gehen Daten rein über
Properties, die kannst du also an diesem Tag setzen
wie HTML-Attribute,
Name ist gleich
und dann im String irgendwie Werte und da kannst du dann
deine geschweiften Klammer
für die JSX-Template-Syntax verwenden.
Und das wird dann quasi gelinkt zu einem zentralen State-Objekt.
Und im Endeffekt, was du immer machst, ist, dass du nicht rumgehst und sagst,
dieses Element kriegt jetzt einen anderen Text oder da wird jetzt was reingelesen
oder da wird jetzt was rausgelesen, sondern du machst quasi immer bloß Binding
zwischen diesem Element und diesem zentralen State-Objekt.
Und du sagst irgendwie, ich ende jetzt mal den State oder diesen Unter-Property von dem State
und dann wird das automatisch alles direkt neu gerendert.
Das macht eigentlich View und React
ziemlich ähnlich.
Und das, was ich mir jetzt angeguckt hatte,
war, wie gesagt, Svelte.
Und Svelte ist eigentlich ein ziemlich witziges Framework,
weil es im Gegensatz zu
View und React, wenn du es baust,
äh,
ja, du baust es,
es wird im Gegensatz zu View und React
nicht ausgeliefert.
Das heißt, du hast einen Compile-Step,
dann wird quasi, nimmt das Framework...
Ach, die anderen machen das nicht? Ah, okay.
Genau, bei den anderen kriegst du halt,
Da wird halt irgendwie so eine zentrale App gestartet,
die springt in den
View- oder React-Code rein, die evaluiert
dann das JSX live
und rendert dann was.
Und bei Svelte
ist das so, dass es zur Compile-Zeit
gemacht wird und das wird dann zu Vanilla
JavaScript runterkompiliert
und ist dementsprechend extrem klein und flott.
Das ist ziemlich witzig.
Ein anderer Unterschied ist auch noch,
dass es nicht JSX verwendet,
sondern HTML pur.
Also JSX ist quasi
dafür braucht man
für React auch einen
Precompile-Step eigentlich.
Daraus werden dann Komponenten
gebaut, aber im Endeffekt ist das Java-Script
und du implementierst immer eine
Komponente, die hat zum Beispiel eine Render-Funktion
und eine On-Update-Funktion
und sowas. Und die Render-Funktion
returnt einen String,
der ein HTML-Tag ist, der ausgefüllt
wird. Und da kannst du dann
JSX macht es dir möglich,
dass du wirklich return und dann
Tag-Klammern schreiben kannst.
und da was reinfüllst.
Das heißt, du hast HTML
in JavaScript.
Obwohl es eigentlich schon seit 100 Jahren
so ist, dass es möglich ist,
JavaScript in HTML
zu haben. Und da hatte
der Entwickler von Svelte
auch ein schönes Beispiel gegeben.
JSX ist problematisch, denn
das hier ist valides HTML, aber kein
valides JSX.
Und das hier ist valides JSX,
aber es ist eigentlich kaputt.
Deswegen machen wir das nicht, deswegen sind
Komponenten zwelt komplett in HTML.
Die haben dann jeweils einen Script-Tag,
wo die gesamte Logik reinkommt.
Und die werden dann geparsed
von einem relativ einfachen Parser
und kompiliert.
Und das ist ziemlich krass. Ich habe eine kleine Oberfläche
für so ein REST-Interface
da mitgebaut.
Und sozusagen die gesamte
Anwendung, die da zum Schluss bei rauskommt, war unter
30 KB.
Das ist wesentlich kleiner als so manches
Framework alleine.
Allerdings ist das ganze Ding noch relativ buggy, also ich würde es jetzt nicht für Produktivsachen empfehlen.
Klingt aber ganz cool.
Wenn du schon gerade meintest, von wegen HTML in JavaScript,
ich hatte letztens so einen sehr coolen Blogpost gelesen, der heißt CSS, A New Kind of JavaScript,
und der geht so ein bisschen drauf ein, von wegen hier,
Styling macht man ja typischerweise auf Seiten hier über diese JavaScript-Attribute und so weiter,
und das ist ja alles ein bisschen kacke, gerade wenn man alle möglichen LSS,
zum Beispiel, wenn man alle Paragraphs
in einem Dokument umstylen möchte
und die alle rot machen möchte, dann muss man das
ein bisschen ekelhaft in JavaScript zusammen machen.
Und gerade wenn man mehrere Elemente selekten möchte,
das ist halt alles nicht so schön.
Und da gibt es jetzt so was Tolles Neues, das nennt sich
Cascading Style Sheets.
Das ist so quasi ein anderer JavaScript-Dialekt
und damit kann man das halt aufziehen
und viel schöner machen. Das läuft viel schneller und viel optimierter,
als wenn man es in JavaScript macht.
Und quasi einfach alten Weinen
in neuen Schläuchen verkauft.
Ja, genau.
Es ist Humor, ohne dass es klingt wie Humor.
Und er verkauft halt CSS
als declarative subset
of JavaScript optimized for styling tasks.
Und...
Sieht tatsächlich, wenn du drüber nachdenkst, ein bisschen aus wie
Jason.
One of the first things you'll notice is the cleaner syntax, which fans of CoffeeScript
will appreciate.
Ich finde das großartig.
Und er verkauft halt CSS neu. Von wegen
nutzt es doch. Wir haben doch sowas Tolles.
Auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe mal in die Showdows rein.
CSS, a new kind of JavaScript.
gibt.
Ja, ich bin alles in allem
trotzdem froh, dass ich nicht
Frontendent-Gutler bin.
Das ist immer bloß zum Spaß oder so, als Nebenprojekt
machen kann. Das geht mir ganz ähnlich.
Das ist überhaupt nicht meine Welt. Ich verkehre mal ein bisschen mit Rumspielen mehr.
Also mehr so auch die Dinge machen, die du da machst.
Aber das ist echt nicht
meine Welt leider.
Dafür machst du doch
so krasse Sachen mit ARKit.
Hast du jetzt immer mal wieder was auf Twitter gepostet?
Das war eine kurze Demo.
Ich fand das cool.
Ich frage mich, wie sich diese API anfühlt.
Du hast auf Twitter
gepostet ein Video, wie du dein Handy,
also wie du das Telefon,
deine Kamera auf so eine
Haltestellentafel ohne Display
gehalten hast und dann hat es daneben
quasi die Live-Informationen
von der DVB in den Raum eingeblendet.
Wie beschreibt man das?
Die Haltestelle hatte übrigens auch
ein Display, das sieht man bloß nicht
auf dem Video.
Also das ist sehr dunkel und das sind diese,
das ist kein Irgendein,
aber ich glaube, es ist kein Irgendein, aber es sieht so ein bisschen sehr dunkel aus
wie diese sehr hässlichen,
die sie jetzt manchen nachrüsten,
um ein bisschen schneller voranzukommen.
Aber nee, abgehend davon, dass man das da nicht sieht.
Das war aber auch nur
als Demo gedacht, dass man halt da das macht.
Was du machst, die API ist relativ simpel.
Also das ist wirklich bloß eine Delegate-Function,
die du implementieren musst.
Du gibst dem Framework hier
eine Reihe von Reference-Images, also für dieses Image-Tracking,
was da ARKit kann.
auf iOS, du gibst eine Reihe von Reference-Images
und sagst, hier such die mal. Und wenn er die
im Viewport findet, dann ruft er diese Delegate-Funktion
auf und sagt dir,
gibt dir ein Objekt
mit den passenden Koordinaten, wo das liegt.
Und was ich dann mache, ist, nehme ich einfach dieses Objekt
und lege, was weiß ich,
20 Zentimeter daneben
und so hoch, mein
Objekt, was ich dann instanziere und das ist dann halt
einfach ein Text-Node
mit Text.
Also das ist schon schön wegabstrich. Das ist super
schick wegabstrahiert und es ist so unglaublich
sauber, dieses Tracking. Das sollte man so viel mehr
mitmachen, mit diesem Image-Tracking.
Die coolsten Demos, die ich bisher gesehen habe,
also mit Abstand die coolste überhaupt,
war, dass du dein
Apple Watch-Display erkennst.
Und auf deinen Armen
neben die Apple Watch
mehr UI-Ligs, die halt
dazugehört. Und dann kannst du da durchscrollen
und Dinge damit interagieren.
Natürlich ist alles an AR
meiner Meinung nach Schrott, bis wir
Brillen haben. Du brauchst
AR-Brille, die du die ganze Zeit trägst und dann ist plötzlich die ganze Welt voll davon.
Und dann hast du so viel mehr davon, als wenn du ein Handy in die Hand nimmst.
Es gibt angeblich jetzt mittlerweile eine japanische Firma,
die es schafft, dir mit Laserbildern auf die Netzhaut zu projizieren.
Wenn man das irgendwie in so eine normale Handelsüberschule Brille einbauen könnte,
dann hast du quasi die ganze Zeit so ein Overlay-Display.
Ja, du brauchst halt, damit das gut funktioniert...
Du kannst natürlich wirklich nichts mehr glauben, was du irgendwo siehst.
Ja, zum einen das, da kommen wir noch in ganz witzige Probleme rein,
Zum anderen, damit AR halt sauber funktioniert,
brauchst du eine Brille mit einer Kamera, die
konstant das filmt, was du siehst. Und es hat auch noch ganz andere
Implikationen, die halt nicht schön sind.
Stimmt. Ja, also ich meine, der Hauptgrund, warum
Google Glass gescheitert ist,
oder hoffentlich gescheitert ist, ist die Tatsache,
dass sie halt eine Kamera mit eingebaut hat.
Hast du es mal ausprobiert, Google Glass?
Leider nicht. Ich hatte nie eine in den Finger
bekommen. Ich hatte auf dem Mobile Camp vor
zwei, drei Jahren mal von
Sascha Pallenberg von mobilegeeks.de
glaube ich, macht der mal eine auf dem Kopf
Ich war, also ich wusste es natürlich vorher auch, aber ich war trotzdem auch in dem Moment, wo ich es ausprobiert hatte, ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass du ja wirklich bloß dieses Gefühl 3x3 cm Display da rechts oben in der Ecke hast, wo du was anzeigen konntest.
Aber man soll es wirklich angucken können, ohne dass man irgendwie einen nahen Punkt anfokussieren soll. Es soll wirklich so aussehen, als wäre es zwei Meter weg.
Das war kein Problem. Du hast es wirklich gut lesen können.
Aber du hast ja trotzdem so eine dicke, also die war nicht groß,
aber die war halt größer als für die Zukunft zulässig, das Google Glass.
Also mein Traum wäre halt, wenn, also das Traum, das klingt mir immer ein bisschen falsch,
aber ich wünschte mir, dass Apple so ein Gerät rausbringt,
was dieselben Frameworks und APIs kann, die ich nutze,
direkt mit meinen Geräteninterface,
schön in diesem World Garden, in dem ich mich eh schon befinde,
sich mit einfindet und alles gut funktioniert.
Ich würde mir so ein Ding auf jeden Fall kaufen, das weiß ich jetzt schon, auch wenn ich halt persönlich mit den Implikationen umgehen müsste, um zu schauen, wann ich es überhaupt nutze. Aber zulegen würde ich es mir einfach nur, weil ich brauche so eine AR-Brille, einfach nur diese ganzen coolen Use Cases für mich mal anwenden zu können.
Auf jeden Fall. Als Google Glass das erste Mal rauskam, kam auch gleichzeitig dieses Squirt-Reading auf. Da hat sie quasi Text genommen und den mittleren Buchstaben, das war eine Lesehilfe, die haben den Text durchgenommen und haben den immer der Reihe nach die Wörter an die gleiche Stelle gelegt.
und zwar so, dass der mittlere Buchstabe auf so einer roten Linie war.
Du musst quasi nur die rote Linie
anfokussieren und dann ist der Text
an dir vorbeigelaufen. Dann hat es dir, der Demo-Text
war, normalerweise liest
man so und so schnell und guck mal, jetzt liest du schon
so und so viele Wörter pro Minute und du kannst aber auch
ohne weiteres das Tempo anheben und hast
so ein bisschen so ein Gaspedal gehabt.
Das gibt es auch irgendwie als Bookmarklet,
dass du das irgendwie Text anmokierst und dann
in deinem Browser auf was klickst und dann dir so eine Seite
erzeugt, wo du das machen kannst.
Und ich habe überlegt, das wäre eigentlich eine witzige Kombination mit
Google Glass gewesen.
dass du in diesem Ding einfach so Texte liest
und dann sitzt
dann kannst du Bücher lesen, dann sitzt du aber eigentlich so apathisch
in deinem Sessel und staust dir die ganze Zeit nach oben
weil du dir ganzen einen Punkt anfokussierst
aber gerade übelst schnell liest
aber deine Augen müssen halt nicht mehr diese
Zeile nachverfolgen, weil der Text an
oben zum Stelle bleibt, sondern wird dir so eingeblendet
und ich dachte mir, das würde Lesen
so richtig gruselig machen, gibt es Leute, die sitzen
dann abends in ihrem Lesesessel
und haben dann keinen dicken Wälzer mehr
auf dem Schoß, sondern setzen sich so eine
Lesebrille auf, Hashtag Lesebrille,
und stand dann
so apathisch in eine Ecke die ganze Zeit.
Das muss ja super fokussiert
dabei bleiben. Das ist halt kein
Late-Back-Lesen, das ist sehr fokussiertes Lesen.
Ich habe das auch länger mal benutzt, also das ist länger, ein paar Wochen mal,
versucht da halt wirklich reinzukommen.
Das ist, also ich finde es auch
sehr angenehm, mal die Möglichkeit zu haben,
schnell zu lesen. Also das spricht wahrscheinlich
dieselben Sachen, die selben
Teile von mir an, die auch mich dazu bringen,
meine Podcasts immer schneller und schneller zu hören.
Weil ich einfach versuche, da möglichst effizient zu sein, aber das ist halt auch nichts, was ich immer beim Lesen dann haben möchte.
Nee, es ist auch ein bisschen...
Das ist sehr unentspannt, sehr, sehr, sehr unentspannt.
Das Problem ist, was du nicht hast, ist, wenn du...
Ich möchte von mir sagen, ich bin kein sonderlich guter Leser.
Wenn du dich dann mal verliest oder was nicht mitbekommen hast, weil es zu schnell an dir vorbeigekommen ist,
kannst du halt eben schnell nochmal eine Zeile zurückspringen bei einem normalen, vertikal zweidimensional ausgelegten und nicht vierdimensional ausgelegten Text.
dann springst du halt mal eine Zeile zurück und schließt sie nochmal
bei Squirt, musstest du dann irgendwie
zurückspulen und dann musstest du halt wie weit.
Das ist halt ein Problem, was...
Du bräuchtest irgendwie noch eine...
Und da kommt jetzt wieder der Medieninformatiker in mir hoch,
du bräuchtest noch eine Visualisierung, wo du im Textgrad bist,
dass du irgendwie einfach dann zurückspulen könntest.
Ja, das ist
gefühlt ein lösbares Problem.
Haben wir aber aktuell noch nicht.
Also eine Lösung für.
Es gibt noch, was ich letztens erst entdeckt hatte,
so ein anderer Ansatz,
Beeline-Reader, nennt sich das Ding.
Die haben, glaube ich, ein Chrome-Addon und auch Apps,
wo du halt prinzipiell einfach mal Artikel von Webseiten reinpackst
oder das Chrome-Addon macht das halt dynamisch direkt,
wenn man ein Chrome-Nutzer ist.
Und die optimieren einfach das Layout,
also nicht das Layout vom Text, die Textfarbe,
sodass eine Zeile zum Zeilenende von einem Absatz
sich langsam in so einem gleichen Gradienten blau wird
und die nächste Zeile auch blau anfängt
und dann aus dem Blau wieder rausgeht.
Und die Zeile darauf wird dann am Ende rot
und die nächste wird dann rot auf.
Genau, das hilft deinen Augen halt sehr, von einer Seite direkt in die nächste zu rutschen, ohne da zu suchen.
Du suchst halt da nicht lange normalerweise.
Das ist eigentlich der Hauptgrund, warum ich häufig, wenn ich was lese, das Fenster, an dem ich das lese, irgendwie ganz nach links, also schmaler mache, damit die Zeilen nicht so lang sind.
Das ist auch ein generelles Problem von Wikipedia, das Wikipedia-artige standardmäßig, da sind die Zeilen zu lang.
Da hast du irgendwie Probleme.
Die Zeitenbreite. Ja, die sind halt Bildschirmbreite.
Der Latex-Default, der wirkt ja immer auch sehr, sehr schmal.
Das Standard-Article-Layout.
Aber da ist ja auch die Idee dahinter,
dass das halt sehr optimiert ist darauf,
lesbar zu sein auf der Seite.
Und wenn du halt danach googelst auch,
hey, wie mache ich das Layout breiter, das sieht kacke aus.
Ja, das Problem ist nicht, dass das Layout zu dünn ist,
sondern dass Seiten zu breit sind für optimales Lese-Layout.
Deswegen, ich habe mich immer gefragt,
warum wissenschaftliche Paper als Vorlage normalerweise so zweispaltig sind.
aber an und für sich finde ich das eigentlich ganz cool, weil es liest sich ganz gut.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Benutzt du eigentlich diesen Service, der dir normale Texte zu Podcasts macht?
Ich hatte mal geschwärmt davon, von narrow.co.
Ah ja, genau.
N-A-R-O-N-A-R-O.co
Die haben ja auch mittlerweile WaveNet eingebaut, was ich super, super cool finde.
Was ist WaveNet?
Diese Text-to-Speech-Engine von Google, die auf ganz viel Machine Learning-Matic basiert und unglaublich real klingt.
Und gerade damit nutze ich das Ding, womit du auch Pizza bestellen kannst.
wahrscheinlich nutzt das Ding auch
unter Under the Hood, geh stark von aus.
Aber es macht jetzt nicht so
Fake-Ums und Ams
und Hums mit einbauen, das nicht.
Obwohl das ja dem Hörgenuss
wahrscheinlich sehr zuträglich wäre.
Zumindest wenn du davon ausgehst, dass dir
jemand was erzählt, nicht dass jemand dir was vorliest.
Also ich
sage häufig bewusst viel
Äh, nur unseren
Zuhörern zuliebe.
Ja, tell yourself that.
Ich weiß, dass ich es mache und ich ärgere mich sehr darüber,
wenn ich mich höre beim Reden.
Tim Pridloth hat irgendwie mal erzählt, dass er sich mal bei einem Podcast
mit einem Gast, der sehr viel äh und öh sagt,
die Mühe gegeben hat, die Mühe gemacht hat,
echt alles, alle Füllwörter
und alle Äms und so rauszuschneiden.
Ach du Scheiße. Und er hat hinterher gemerkt,
das Ergebnis klang sehr artifiziell.
Deswegen hat er es dann irgendwie,
glaube ich, gar nicht mehr gemacht.
Gar nicht so veröffentlicht.
Interessant.
Nee, fuck, wo war er gerade?
Naroko. Also benutzt du das?
Achso, Narrow. Selten.
Also gerade wenn es das Problem ist,
die meisten Sachen, die ich mir in meine Readinglist packe,
beinhalten halt irgendwo Code.
Und da kannst du gleich vergessen.
Das bricht dann auseinander.
Und wenn es irgendwelche Hacker-News-Posts sind,
die halt mal wirklich von irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
das ist auch eine Sache, die mich stört.
Das ist schon zum fünften Mal heute auch.
Da darfst du einfach nicht drauf achten eigentlich.
Das kann ich nicht drauf achten.
Das hört sich auch weg eigentlich beim Zuhören.
Jetzt werden es wahrscheinlich alle merken.
Du schnellst es raus.
Hier schneide ich nicht.
Wenn ich auf Hacker-News mal so einen Post finde
vom New Yorker oder so. Irgendwas, was halt wirklich Text ist.
Sowas haue ich dann tatsächlich öfter mal in Narrow rein,
höre das dann auch später und das klingt auch echt ganz gut
mit Dank des WaveNet Text-to-Speech-Engines.
Das finde ich nicht sehr angenehm.
Muss ich echt mal ausprobieren. Also ich habe dann häufig, wenn ich irgendwas sehe,
dann schicke ich mir das entweder direkt, ich habe ja alle meine Geräte
mit hier Firefox Sync verknüpft, schicke ich mir das direkt auf
mein Tablet oder auf mein Telefon zum Lesen oder ich
speichere mir das in mein Pocket.
Wo Pocket ist wirklich jetzt, also mein Pocket ist voll
mit super tollen Artikeln,
die ich alle irgendwann mal noch lesen muss, weil ich da tatsächlich
nie wirklich reinguck. Das Problem habe ich genauso.
Safari hat die seit einer Weile eingebaut. Entweder man liest es sofort,
dieses, ich lese es später.
Meine Reading-List ist
The Place Where Articles Go to Die. Die ist
ultra lang, das Ding, also ich gehe hin und
wieder mal durch, jetzt lösche ich immer alles raus, was ich je nicht mehr lese.
Und wenn ich ganz unten anfange, dann so,
das ist interessant, das ist spannend, das ist spannend, das ist spannend.
Fuck, ich will es eigentlich überhaupt nicht davon löschen.
Die Endless Backlog.
Ja, das ist halt, vor allem diese Safari eingebaut,
die ist direkt hier in der Sidebar und die blende ich halt
aus, weil sie einfach nur
sehr mit dem motivierend ist, wie lange die mittlerweile ist.
Obwohl jetzt, ich kenne ja
viele Leute, die hatten dann irgendwie 35.000
Tabs offen, weil sie halt keine
Bookmarks verwendet haben, sondern sich immer, ach das ist
interessant, den Tab lasse ich mal auf.
Das Problem höre ich auch. Und oftmals
gehe ich da mal durch und haue Tabs in die
Readinglist, bewusst mit dem
Gedanken, ja das werde ich halt niemals lesen.
Das ist jetzt abgelaufen.
Das ist so der Unterschied zwischen Register, RAM und
Langzeitspeicher.
Die liegen im Archiv genau.
Ja, bei mir ist es dann, ich schiebe das dann in die Pocket
und da lese ich es dann. Ja, aber ich habe dann zumindest,
kriege ich die Tabs immer zu. Außer auf meinem
Telefon, da werden die Tabs irgendwie immer mehr. Ich habe
mittlerweile in meinem Firefox, auf meinem Handy, glaube ich
90 Tabs offen.
Ja, auf dem Telefon kann ich rigoros Dickel immer
schließen, weil da habe ich nichts offen, was ich auch länger offen
haben möchte. Wenn ich mir was merken möchte, dann maile
ich mir das immer direkt zu vom Handy aus
und dann öffne ich dieses. Mail?
Ich schicke mir selber tagtäglich um die 50, 70
Mails, irgendwas um den Dreh rum, habe ich da jetzt mal geschaut.
Das ist ganz schlimm. Das ist so eine Angewohnheit,
die kriege ich nicht los, wenn ich Dinge
mir selber merken lasse, dann geht das nur
per Mail. Das kann nur so.
Also wirklich mit Abstand,
die meisten Mails von mir gehen an mich selber.
Ja, dafür benutze ich halt, wie gesagt,
hier Firefox Sync. Da kann man sich dann,
da geht dann einfach in dem nächsten der Tab auf.
Das finde ich ganz gut.
Also Apple synkt auch die Tabs.
Und was ich manchmal tatsächlich mache, was sinnvoll ist,
es gibt ein so ein, von Firefox
gibt es ja dieses Testpilot-Dings,
die bauen irgendwie eigene Add-ons,
die dann evaluiert werden.
Und da sind halt ein paar schöne Sachen dabei rausgefallen.
Das eine waren diese Tab-Container,
die wir schon mal erwähnt hatten.
Die benutze ich jetzt echt dauerhaft.
Weil da kannst du sagen, ich mache meine Work-Tabs,
also die Sachen, die ich auf Arbeit verwende.
Gut, man könnte auch einen komplett anderen Browser dafür nehmen
und mit einem anderen Profil,
aber ich mische das da an der Stelle.
Dann mache ich die halt aber trotzdem in diesem Work-Container auf
und dann teilen die sich halt wirklich keine Cookies
und keine Login-Daten.
Und da kannst du aber auch sagen,
jetzt mache ich alle Work-Container zu
und das nächste Mal, wenn ich
am Montag wieder auf Arbeit gehe,
dann sage ich, ich mache jetzt alle Workcontainer auf
und dann gehen halt alle meine arbeitsinternen
Bitbucket und Jira
und Sachen wieder auf.
Das will ich in Safari. Also ich kann nicht weg von Safari.
Ich hänge zu sehr an Safari.
Und das hätte ich aber gerne als Feature. Das ist schon cool.
Und eine andere Sache, die sie eingebaut hatten,
waren Snooze-Tabs. Da kann sie sagen,
mach diesen Tab zu, aber mach ihn heute Abend,
morgen früh, nächste Woche,
dieses Wochenende,
Montag, den 23. Mai 1782
sich wieder auf. Nee, ich glaube,
in der Vergangenheit funktioniert das nicht, aber
dann verschwindet der und irgendwann
plopp, ist er wieder da. Solange man dem Feature
vertrauen kann. Wunderbar.
Ja, ich meine, wenn du dir jetzt sagst, mach mir das
in einer Woche wieder auf und dann ist es passiert
es halt nicht, dann merkt es, glaube ich.
Sobald ich mich daran erinnere, dass es einmal nicht geklappt, dann kann ich das Feature nie wieder benutzen.
Nee, aber es klappt eigentlich ganz gut.
Das Safari Reading-Gest hat mich auch mal
verarscht. Da habe ich auf iOS
Dinge draufgespeichert und die waren einfach weg.
Und das ärgert mich bis heute. Das ist locker
zwei, drei Jahre her oder so. Das ärgert mich immer noch.
Du weißt doch bis heute nicht wieder, was du eigentlich bist.
Nee, natürlich. Ich würde mich auch nie daran erinnern können.
Das waren tolle Dinge, das weiß ich.
Oh Mann.
Was ist noch so passiert in der Welt?
Hast du wirklich gekriegt, dass Guido Van Rossum
nicht mehr Pythons Benevolent Dictator for Life ist?
Es ist an irgendeinem...
Ich habe neulich mal wieder von Guido und dem
Benevolent Dictator-Modell
ich glaube im Changelog gehört, aber ich habe
in dem Zusammenhang nicht gecheckt, dass es darum ging,
dass der aufgehört hat.
Nee, krass. Und ist jetzt Python quasi
orphaned, oder was?
Python, das jetzt tot ist, vorbei.
Die machen jetzt alle Rast.
Nee, natürlich geht Python weiter.
Und es gibt jetzt kein BDFL mehr.
Und das Python Core Team hat halt jetzt
das Ding in der Hand.
Was macht Guido jetzt?
Weiter bei Dropbox arbeiten macht er doch eigentlich, oder?
Keine Ahnung, was da noch.
Ich habe tatsächlich, um sich jetzt gestehen,
seine Mail nicht durchgelesen.
Aber nochmal Zusammenfassung.
Python ist ja eine Skriptsprache.
Die gibt es seit Anfang der 90er.
Es gibt es länger als Java, habe ich letztens gesagt.
Das muss ich immer wieder vor Augen halten.
länger als Java, wenn du drüber nachdenkst.
So mal,
FGBP
Language
gibt es glaube ich seit 92
oder so. Seit 90.
Das ist halt so ein Projekt, was der Guido
irgendwie jahrelang entwickelt hat und das hat er
sich auch nie so aus der Hand nehmen lassen. Da haben andere Leute
mitgemacht, aber er hatte bei allen Features und
Eigenschaften der Sprache immer das letzte Wort.
Ergo war er der
benevolent dictator, also der
freundliche Diktator dieser Sprache. Genau.
Und das auf Lebenszeit. Also bis jetzt.
Und es gibt halt viele Diskussionen
bei unterschiedlichen Projekten, die
argumentieren, was so für
Community-Organisationsmodelle
sich für welche Projekte am besten
eignen. Bei Rust gab es ja auch
den Graydon Hoare, der die Sprache erfunden
hat und der ist allerdings...
Ach, du meinst den Swift-Infektor.
Ja, genau.
Und bei...
Wo wollte ich jetzt als nächstes hin?
Bei Ruby on Rails
gibt es den DHH, der von Anfang an dabei war
und der immer noch... Der DHH ist ja mehr der Rails-Typ.
Aber der ist der Rails Benevolent Dictator.
Das stimmt.
Der ist auf jeden Fall der BDF-FM.
Bei Rust ist es so, dass es den einen Typen gab,
der das maßgeblich getrieben hat am Anfang.
Der ist aber schon ein, zwei Jahre
bevor 1.0 rauskam, ist der eigentlich aus dem
Core-Team, hat sich zurückgezogen und nimmt jetzt nicht
mehr wirklich so aktiv an der Entwicklung teil.
Und das hat dem Projekt eigentlich gut getan,
weil es dadurch nicht alles
von E-Mapping und die sind dann zu diesem
RFC-Prozess
übergegangen. Da klappt es auch echt großartig.
Da läuft es ziemlich gut. Genau, dann gibt es Projekte,
die auf der Welt verteilt laufen, wie C++,
die überhaupt keinen Benevolent Dictator haben,
aber wahrscheinlich eigentlich bräuchten,
wenn man sich das so anguckt.
Das war so ein schönes Negativbeispiel für Sprachentwicklung.
Ja, und bei Python ist es der Guido Van Rossum
und das hat an und für sich, glaube ich,
ganz gut funktioniert.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich meine, da gibt es bestimmt auch Geschichten von Leuten,
die sagen, ich hätte gerne das und das mit in die Sprache
und der Guido hat es einfach abgeblockt.
Da stecke ich jetzt nicht so sehr an dieser Python-Entwicklung drin,
dass ich das wüsste.
Aber, wenn du dir mal Python vor 15 Jahren anschaust,
das ist tatsächlich
sehr, sehr verwandt dem aktuellen Python.
Das ist quasi dieselbe Sprache. Natürlich,
etliche Features sind dazugekommen in den letzten 15 Jahren,
aber 20 Jahren sogar,
ist ja jetzt, wie gesagt, älter als ich, dementsprechend ist Python
jetzt 27,
oder 28 sogar.
Aber da ist halt echt viel passiert.
Ich meine,
die andere Seite, da ist viel passiert, aber
du erkennst die Sprache halt wieder und die Grundprinzipien
haben sich nie verändert und das ist echt wertvoll,
gerade über die Zeit.
Aber ich meine, die Grundprinzipien
einer Programmiersprache änderst du ja nicht. Das ist ja auch
bei anderen Sprachen, die so alt sind.
Kannst du und da
ändert sich auch vieles. Wenn du die andere Sprache
anguckst, ja. Schau dir mal Zipus Plus
vor 20 Jahren an. Das stimmt schon.
Java hat sich jetzt auch dolle verändert.
Ruby hat
sich, naja, Ruby war immer mal wieder
zwischendurch inkompatibel. Die haben es aber irgendwie geschafft,
die Sprache kontinuierlicher
zu verändern als
Python. Python hat ja immer noch das Problem,
dass jetzt mittlerweile gibt es
Python 3.7. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt
2.7 und 3.7.
Und ich glaube, sie haben es
immer noch nicht geschafft.
Also wir haben irgendwie
intern so eine Testing
Suite Codebase, die in Python gebaut
ist und da sind die Leute, die bauen, stolz
drauf, dass die mit Python 3 und 2
kompatibel ist. Da denkst du, wenn du sowas machst,
dann hast du doch den kleinsten
gemeinsamen Nenner an Sprachfeatures. Warum
macht man sowas überhaupt? Ich meine, es ist ja schön, wenn es mit
beiden funktioniert, aber Python 2 könnte echt mal
sterben. Das ist schon lange, lange, lange,
lange, lange überfällig. Vielleicht ist man natürlich
kein Arsch, wie ich gerade gemeint habe, wenn man Python 2 verwendet
heute noch oder ausschließlich Python 2.
Aber nein, das ist einfach falsch.
Python 2 ist vorbei.
Es gibt halt,
das Software
verrottet ist halt was, was du akzeptieren musst.
Und es gibt viele,
viele sehr verbreitete
Projekte, die in Python 2
geschrieben sind und die Leute sich denken,
das könnte man,
das funktioniert halt. Warum
machen und da ist halt die Entwicklung wahrscheinlich bei vielen Projekten
auch schon vor Jahren eingeschlafen,
aber wenn du jetzt auf den ganzen
Distros standmäßig Python 3 ausliefern würdest,
wie es zum Beispiel Arch Linux schon macht,
dann wären viele Anwendungen kaputt.
Das ist was, was
dir an C++
nicht passiert oder
vielleicht nicht unbedingt passiert, weil du kannst immer noch sagen,
ich kompiliere das jetzt mit einem Flag, der
das mit alten Sprachfeatures ausführt
oder in der JavaScript-Welt sagst du,
da machen wir jetzt einfach mal, da gibt es jetzt
ein Babel und dann kompilieren wir das um in eine
Standard oder wir kopulieren das
für eine ältere Engine, wenn wir müssen,
zu einem älteren Standard um.
Bei Python,
es gibt irgendwie Python Modernized, das wäre jetzt wieder was,
wo ich gerne heute den Gast, der uns leider
kurzfristig abgesagt hat, befragt hätte,
der hätte sich damit sehr gut ausgekannt.
Bei Python gab es auch so ein
Modernizing-Skript, aber das hat halt
nicht dazu geführt, dass
jetzt Projekte, die verbreitet sind und immer noch
auf Python 2 laufen,
komplett darauf umgestiegen werden.
Also wie gesagt, momentan benutzen immer noch Leute
2. Ja, Python 2.7.15
ist übrigens das Python, was auch auf macOS
Mojave das einzige ist,
was vorinstalliert ist.
So, jetzt können wir uns mal über, weil wir uns ja schon überlegt
hatten, dass wir jetzt bis zur
nächsten
Season
anonymisierbar Spanisch lernen, würdest du sagen
Mojave oder Mojave?
Ich bin bei Mojave.
Mojave? Ich komme nicht weg.
Ich behaupte auch, dass das so
die Aussprache ist, die am verbreitetsten
in den USA ist, aber ich weiß es jetzt nicht.
Ich bin mein Mojavi.
Weil man sagt ja auch nicht San Jose, sondern San Jose.
San Jose.
Okay, wir haben offenbar beide keine Ahnung von Spanisch.
Lass uns wieder über Programmiersprachen reden.
Folge 30.
Graydon Hall gehört so zu den Leuten,
die irgendwie, also zu einer relativ großen Abteilung von Leuten,
die von Anfang vier an Rust gemacht haben
und jetzt haben wir an Swift arbeiten,
was eigentlich ganz gut für Swift ist,
wo allerdings mit diesen Leuten ziemlich leid tun,
weil die kennen jetzt Rust und haben daran gearbeitet
und müssen jetzt an dem Swift-Compiler arbeiten,
der in C++ geschrieben ist.
Schrecklich.
Und ich kann mich an einen Tweet von Graydon Hoare erinnern,
der geschrieben hat,
ich habe mich jetzt mehrere Stunden lang mit Speicherproblemen
oder mit Speicherunsicherheiten und Lifetimes auseinandergesetzt,
aber I have it from great authority that I only need to improve and learn
and it will get better over time.
Der programmiert aber auch schon seit 20 Jahren.
Das Problem bei uns ist, dass du halt 30 Jahre Erfahrung
haben kannst, du dich ja trotzdem noch mit solchen Problemen
umschlägst.
Der Tweet muss ich mal raussuchen.
Aber wo wir schon gerade bei Swift sind,
der Schmidtlauch hatte mir
letztens geschrieben und hat
gemeint, dass für uns als inoffiziellen
Fachpodcast für Sprachgelaber,
was ich ein wunderschönes Label finde,
das sollten wir uns wirklich auf die Fahnen schreiben.
Akonomi ist ja aber der inoffizielle Sprachlaber-Podcast.
Genau.
Hat bei uns empfohlen die aktuelle
Folge der Freakshow. Das war ein
vierstündiges Interview mit Marky Dom.
Ja, die Freakshow halt, ne?
Das ist der Typ, der, ich weiß nicht,
den Editor Sub Ether Edit
vielleicht noch kennst, sehr lange her.
Ja, ja. Das war das, was auch
kollaboratives Editing konnte, lange bevor es
irgendwie diese Webplattformen gab,
die dann später das fortgesetzt haben.
Die Folge Mein Hut hell brennt?
Vom 6. Juli?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Was steht denn da noch so? Ich habe den Titel
jetzt nicht im Kopf. Kann sein.
Letzte Freakshow vor der Sommerpause.
Ja doch, das ist die.
Genau. Und zwar
der Typ, der auch Karkasonnen entwickelt
hat und dieses wunderbar
tolle iOS-App dafür, die ist echt große Klasse,
der hat die letzten drei Jahre bei Apple gearbeitet
und hat jetzt
aufgehört und hat direkt nachdem er aufgehört
hat erstmal einen kleinen,
ich will nicht sagen Shitstorm, einen kleinen Storm
losgetreten online über
Swift an sich, weil er
alles kritisiert hat, was er in der Sprache
nicht toll findet und was
schief läuft generell am Prozess.
Das hat er in dem Podcast alles erwähnt?
Es ging auch um diesen Tweet
beziehungsweise um den Blog-Post
und alles, was darüber
online losgetreten hat,
hat es unglaublich die Runden gemacht.
Da sind auch viele valide Kritikpunkte mit drin.
Vieles, wo ich jetzt nicht mitgehen würde.
Vieles, wo ich mitgehen würde.
Was noch verbessert werden muss.
Er hat an vielen Stellen, wie gesagt, auch recht.
Wie gesagt, vielleicht habe ich einfach ein bisschen
Kool-Aid getrunken. An manchen Punkten möchte ich ihm nicht
zustimmen, dem Post packen wir auf jeden Fall mit in die Schorlundsend rein,
so sich hier sein eigenes Bild dazu bilden.
Aber kannst du irgendwie ein kurzes
Beispiel geben? Ein Problem,
was er generell mit anmeint, ist, dass Swift
versucht zu viel zu können und nichts
davon richtig wirklich umsetzt.
Also es soll ja laut Chris Lattner
die Sprache sein, die die Welt übernimmt,
World Domination bekommt und jetzt eine Systems
Programming Language ist eine Scripting-Sprache und nichts
davon ist wirklich drin und du hast halt
diesen ganzen Interop mit Objective-C,
der dir... Das ist
halt auch so ein bisschen das, was
wir und viele Leute auch halt an
Zykluss kritisieren, dass zu viel in dieser
Sprache drin ist und die sich
eigentlich, das Schöne ist, wenn du so
eine Domainsprache hast, die sich vom Feature Set auf eine
bestimmte Sache reduziert.
Ich habe neulich
ein Panel gesehen auf der
JSConf 2018, da gibt es auch
ein paar sehr schöne Vorträge, die ich nur empfehlen kann.
Einer davon von dem
Svelte-Entwickler über Svelte,
Svelte,
ich habe lange gedacht, das ist schwedisch,
dieser Vortrag ist fürchterlich schief gegangen,
aber ich empfehle ihn trotzdem. Kann man sich übrigens
angucken auf einer neuen Plattform, die ich gefunden habe,
Dev.Tube.
Das sind nur solche Vorträge
von irgendwelchen Dev-Vorträgen
und solche entwicklerspezifischen Videos.
Also Dev.Tube. Und zumindest auf der
JS-Conf war halt auch so ein Panel
zum Schluss mit mehreren
zehn Leuten vom TC39.
TC39 ist dieses
Standardisierungs-Comedy von JavaScript,
die irgendwie auch zu einer meiner
Tipps, die ich hier abgeben wollte, eine neue Webseite
vorgestellt haben, die ist die Flurry9, wo man die
aktuellen Sprachproposals für
die nächsten JavaScript-Standards
schön übersichtlich sehen kann.
Und da hatte einer auch erwähnt, naja, wir hatten überlegt,
da ging es um das Feature
Private Properties auf JavaScript, die neu hinzugefügt
wurden, warum sie sich denn da ausgerechnet
für dieses,
für den Lattenzaun als
Anfang für Private Properties entschieden
haben und so weiter und so fort.
Und warum sie nicht noch das einbauen wollen und
wie sie das und das einbauen wollen.
ist der Begriff Syntax-Budget gefallen.
Wir würden gerne diese und jede Features einbauen,
aber man muss halt immer bedenken,
dass die Sprache halt irgendwann sehr, sehr syntaktisch,
sehr, sehr komplex wird.
Und es wäre halt schön,
wenn man bestimmte Sachen halt nicht mit Syntax machen würde,
sondern sie zum Beispiel in der Standard-Bibliothek sieht.
Das ist eine Sache, die Rust sehr exzessiv gemacht hat,
bevor 1.0 rauskam, sind sehr viele Sachen,
die in einer früheren, sagen wir, prähistorischen Version von Rust
mit Syntax gemacht hast, machst du halt
jetzt mittlerweile nicht mehr über Syntax, sondern
es sind Standard-Bibliotheks-Features und das hat
den Vorteil, dass du es besser suchen und
besser erlernen kannst, weil es halt in Worten
beschrieben ist und besser dokumentierbar ist.
Bei Swift, ich muss
sagen, ich habe nicht viel Swift gemacht, aber jedes Mal, wenn ich
reingeguckt habe, oder es gab diese schöne
Reihe von, wir vergleichen
Swift mit Rust, Blogposts
von Chris Kreitchow,
kann man auch nochmal verlinken, da habe ich dann jedes Mal gedacht,
naja, Swift hat ehrlich gesagt
sein Syntax-Budget schon
überschreitet.
Genau das Sprechenverbrauch.
Wir haben die vielleicht in den Schoen uns einen Link dazu,
haben wir selber nicht angeschaut,
haben nur im Kopf, was sie gesagt haben,
dass ein Vergleich von verschiedenen Sprachen
gibt es wohl irgendwo, wo die Menge an Syntax
verglichen wurde, die die Sprachen haben.
Swift hat ein unglaubliches Pensum,
das überschreit wohl die meisten Sachen
und es könnte sogar
ein Vergleich von Richiecki gewesen sein,
der dann am Ende Closure mit Anzeige von wegen
ja, Syntax haben wir quasi gar nichts
hier, es gibt Klammern, das war's.
Und alles andere ist halt eine Funktion.
Es gibt halt, Closure hat halt
keine Syntax per se, außer Klammern.
Und selbst die paar Operatoren
sind halt, also gibt es überhaupt
eine Operat? Ja doch, gibt es eine Operat.
Das sind halt Funktionen, die halt einfach definiert sind.
Und ja, sie merken es auch
in der, wie gesagt, in der Füchscher auch nochmal mit an,
dass man Sprachen generell
toll finden kann,
aufgrund der Tatsache, ob sie
keine Custom-Operatoren
Das muss ich rückblickend sagen.
Anfangs fand ich es geil. Ja, Swift kann das,
super cool, dann kann ich es nutzen, wenn ich es möchte.
Aber wann will man das?
Super selten. Es gibt so die ein, zwei,
maximal so drei Anwendungsfälle,
wo man wirklich mal so einen Custom Operator
haben möchte. Overloading,
klar, keine Ahnung.
Ja, aber Custom Operators sind einfach bloß,
die machen nicht mehr als
eine Infix-Schreibweise einer Funktion.
Ja, und das wird halt super verwirrend für Leute,
die nicht im Kopf
den Cognitive Overhead haben,
das sich vor Augen zu halten, was genau das tut.
Bei Ruby kannst du ja einfach neue Operationen
als Objekte, als Properties
oder als Methoden auf einer Klasse definieren
und dann kannst du es so schreiben,
dass du einfach deine Leerzeichen drin lässt
und dann hast du, wenn der von deiner Operation
der erste, das den Operator als Methode implementiert,
dann kannst du diesen Operator benutzen.
Gibt es halt nur Postfix und Infix-Operatoren,
keine Prefix?
Genau.
beziehungsweise ist halt dann auch nicht kommutativ.
Das heißt, wenn das eine vorne plötzlich einen anderen Typen hat,
dann gibt es das nicht mehr.
Das ist auch gut.
Okay, witzig.
Aber eigentlich so Operatoren neu definieren können,
ist eigentlich kein schönes Feature.
Nee, und ich habe auch selten ein Projekt.
Also gerade wenn wirklich ich der Endnutzer von einem Projekt bin,
dann manchmal, wenn ich witzig bin,
okay, kommt sowas rein.
In der Library würde ich sowas nie mehr sehen.
Never, ever, ever.
Es sei denn, wie gesagt, der ganze Zweck davon.
Also keine Ahnung, wenn du so wegkommutifikation machst.
Also es muss dann wirklich idiomatisch zu dem,
was die Library macht, wirklich passen.
Ja, und da hat man jetzt halt dieses eine Beispiel von
Vector- und Matrix-Datentypen,
die halt irgendwie
dort als Operator mit drin haben,
um da jetzt eine Dings...
Manchmal ist sowas auch ganz witzig. Ich könnte mir jetzt vorstellen,
war das bei Swift, wo
für Path-Objekte
der Slash-Apparator überladen war
zum Konkatenieren, sodass du
einen Path Slash, einen anderen Path hinschreiben
konntest, so wie es auch wäre. Das ist kein Standard-Feature,
aber ich meine, eine Library gesehen zu haben, die genau
das tut, ja. Das ist ja
Aber das ist halt auch,
du dividierst halt irgendwelche Stringen,
sowas, was genau tut, dass du dir, ah klar, das ist der Pfad,
ist das cool? Ich weiß
nicht.
Noch ein kurzer anderer Ausflug,
wir sind gerade bei uns auf Arbeit
dabei, ein
sehr
eingesessenes und auch eigentlich gut
funktionierendes Stück
JavaScript-Code nach TypeScript zu
migrieren, zum einen, weil wir es halt mit dem
anderen TypeScript-Code mittlerweile
kombinieren möchten.
Und da sind wir halt gerade dabei,
nachträglich so existierenden JavaScript-Codes
zu typisieren. Deswegen habe ich jetzt mehr und mehr von
Visual Studio Code mal diese Refactoring-
Funktionalitäten verwendet. Du sagst halt
erst, ich will machen jetzt aus dem,
der Code sieht so aus, du hast
eine Funktion und das ist eigentlich eine Klasse,
aber du hast eine Prototyp-Funktion
und dann hast du hinterher auf dieser Funktion und sagst
ja in JavaScript.prototype.irgendwas
ist gleich diese Funktion, um
da kann dir VSCode relativ gut
einfach eine Klasse draus machen und dann kannst du
noch ein bisschen Sachen hin und her schaffeln
dann machst du TypeScript draus, benennst die
Datei um und dann
kommen mittlerweile ganz viele Fehler
die da einfach fix und zack hast du das
integriert, das läuft eigentlich ganz gut
da habe ich aber so festgestellt, was VSCode
hat relativ viele Refactoring Features
sowas habe ich eigentlich nie benutzt
an irgendeiner Stelle habe ich den Schock bekommen
als er mir auf ein Property auf einer
Klasse mit Rechtsklick
angeboten hat, Gitter und Zetter dafür zu erzeugen.
Da habe ich draufgeklickt, dann hat er mir,
das gibt es bei
JavaScript seit ES
2015, gibt es dieses Get und Z-Property,
wo du
quasi einen Methodenaufruf
hinter ein Property so verstecken kannst,
dass es für dich aussieht, als ob du es zuweist,
aber eigentlich wird eine Methode aufgerufen.
Das gibt es auch bei
Python.
Da habe ich mir erst mal gedacht,
mein Gott, wenn ich das
mache, dann sieht das aus wie Java.
schrecklich. Ganz schlimm. Und Java
gab es jetzt nämlich in einen
Blogpost, weil die jetzt Type-Inference kriegen.
In der nächsten Version. Java 10?
Ich habe den Überblick verloren.
10 ist glaube ich.
Jetzt musst du die Typen nicht mehr vorne und hinten schreiben,
sondern du schreibst jetzt vorne var.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ich möchte mir eigentlich Java
nicht mehr angucken, weil
wenn ich mir das angucke, sieht das bestimmt dann aus wie TypeScript
und dann denke ich mir, ich schreibe eigentlich den ganzen Tag Java.
Deswegen
kriege ich dann einen Schrück.
Schön, wir würden noch in den ersten Vorlesungen
erzählt wurde von wegen Java und
JavaScript, wer das behauptet, das sei das
Gleiche, der hat überhaupt keine Ahnung und bla bla bla
und mittlerweile Sehnsprachen
taktisch sich einfach so ähnlich.
Ja, ich müsste mich
nochmal damit auseinandersetzen, ich finde eigentlich das
TypeScript-Typ-System
ziemlich schön.
Die kriegen jetzt auch relativ, also
die sind halt dabei sehr
darauf bedacht, eigentlich nur
weiterhin JavaScript zu machen und nichts
Neues zu machen, sondern einfach ein Typsystem
anzubieten, mit dem du
JavaScript gut beschreiben kannst.
Es gibt zum Beispiel, alles ist per Default
der Any-Typ und auf dem
Any-Typ geht alles.
Und in der nächsten Version, TypeScript 3,
das Problem mit dem Any-Typ,
wenn du einmal irgendwo explizit
sagst, dieses Ding ist Any, kannst du da
wirklich alles mitmachen. Das heißt, du kannst da
Unter-Properties und Unter-Under-Properties
drauf aufrufen, da ist wirklich kein
statischer Check mehr angeschaltet, was
dazu führt, dass du dann halt irgendwie was reinkriegst
in der Methode, dann sagst du Any drauf
und dann hilft dir der Compiler wirklich nicht mehr.
Das brauchst du für Interop auch, ganz klar.
Das brauchst du für Interop, aber es ist halt nicht wirklich hilfreich,
weil du damit eigentlich den Check einfach nur ausmachst.
Was wir jetzt bei TypeScript 3,
was wir jetzt vor ein paar Tagen als Preview vorgestellt haben,
einführen werden, ist der Unknown-Typ.
Okay.
Was für Interop an dieser Stelle wahrscheinlich wesentlich besser ist.
Der TypeScript-Compiler funktioniert so,
du kannst Typeguards definieren.
Das ist eine Funktion, die einen Boolean zurückgibt,
wo du innen drin einen Check auf bestimmte Eigenschaften
von dem Objekt, was du reingibst, machst.
Aber du schreibst in die Typsignatur hintendran
nicht einfach bool, sondern
ist dieser Typ.
Und dann hast du deine Funktion,
die zurückgibt.
Ich kriege irgendein Objekt rein
und ich teste, ob das
das Objekt Person ist.
Ob das mein Interface-Person erfüllt.
Das wird dann zur Runtime gemacht.
Und wenn du diese Funktion schreibst,
dann kriegst du das halt rein.
Prüfst du, es hat das Property Name.
Name ist String zum Beispiel
und dann returnst du
isPerson und dann kann der TypeScript
Compiler, wenn du diese Funktion am Anfang
schreibst, dir danach
glaubt er dir dann, dass du danach
wirklich eine Person reingekriegt hast.
Das machst du halt an Stellen, wo du Code
von außen reinkriegst, wenn du selber
nicht geschrieben hast. Ich erinnere mich gerade sehr an dieses Feature
von Vigil, dieser esoterischen Sprache, die ich
in meinem Lightning Talk erzählt hatte, wo du
am Ende versprichst, dass du das
hier zurückgibst und wenn du dein Versprechen
brichst, dann wird dein Code gelöscht.
ähm, zumindest mit TypeScript 3
ähm, du nimmst halt so
Annie an und dann machst du diesen Check
und dann, ähm
kannst du damit weitermachen, allerdings
wenn du das als Annie annimmst, kannst du halt sofort damit
eigentlich weitermachen, das ist also nicht wirklich hilfreich statisch
deswegen haben sie jetzt für TypeScript 3 den
Unknown Type hinzugefügt, der ist ähnlich
wie Annie, du kannst alles drauf zuweisen
ähm, das Problem
ist bloß, dass, was der
Unterschied ist, dass du danach nicht alles damit machen kannst
du musst, der sagt
den immer bei allem, was du darauf machst,
das kann das Ding nicht. Das ist da nicht drin.
Und so weiter, dann kriegst du immer rote Linien.
Du musst quasi am Anfang Typeguards verwenden,
um den Compiler erstmal
durch Code, den du zur Runtime dann
ausführen lässt, zu beweisen,
dass dieses Objekt
wirklich diese Eigenschaften hat und dadurch
hast du wirklich wesentlich bessere Hilfe,
um
solche Probleme zu umgehen.
Das klingt cool.
Ja, der Anon-Type.
Das war jetzt etwas aus
aus dem Stehgreif erzählt und wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
hasplig.
Wenn wir schon,
jetzt habe ich noch eine Überleitung, schon beim
JavaScript-Universum sind,
hast du das von ESLint
mitbekommen?
Ja, natürlich, es ist der NPM-Fuck
ab der Woche.
Weil,
es ist schwierig, hier irgendjemandem den Fuckab zuzuschieben.
Das Problem ist halt, vor allem
an der Stelle, also natürlich kann es immer passieren...
Wachst du die Geschichte erst mal erzählen?
Ja, wahrscheinlich besser. Also ESLint,
Generell ist ein Linter für
JavaScript. ESLint wie ECMAScript.
Genau. Nutzen sehr viele und
da hat einer der Hauptentwickler seine
Credentials wurden compromised und
jemand hat es geschafft, mit dem sein
Access, mit dem sein Keys, oder mit dem sein Credentials
Sag mal nicht mit dem sein.
Ah, fuck, zu bayerisch aufgezogen worden.
Das Problem wieder. Jemand hat es
geschafft, mit dessen Credentials
ein Update zu ESLint
auf NPM zu publishen, dass
wenn du es ausführst, deine NPM
RC nimmt und die
also das Zettel von Pastebin-Code runter
und führt den aus, was dann deine
NPM RC genommen hat und die zu irgendeinem Web-Service hochgeschoben hat.
Um somit möglichst mehr Credentials zu
harvesten.
Aber nur deine NPM RC?
Insofern sich das nicht verändert hat,
was in diesem Pastebin stand,
insofern ich das mitbekommen habe, war das erstmal das.
Genau. Vielleicht auch deine Endphase mit dazu,
weil warum nicht?
Jedenfalls, das Witzige daran ist halt
nach wie vor, sowas kann passieren, egal
in welchem Ökosystem. Das Problem ist halt,
das JavaScript-Universum, dass du das halt von NPM runterziehst
und dass es halt mit
vollen Rechten immer so ausgeführt wird,
einfach so auf deinem System.
Yay.
Das war einer der 10 Regrets über
Node.js von Ryan Dahl.
Ach, der Node-Erfinder.
Der Node-Erfinder, genau. Der hatte auch
auf dieser JS-Conf, kann ich mal verlinken,
einen Vortrag gehalten, 10 Things I Regret
über
Node.js.
Das war ein klassischer
klassisches Beispiel für
Two Hard Things About Computer Science,
wo dann das dritte Off-by-One-Error war.
Naming Things, Cache Validation
und Off-by-One-Error.
Denn diese 10 Regrets waren eigentlich
nur 7 Regrets.
Aber der hat auch gemeint, eigentlich hätte es mehr
Sandbox-designen müssen und du hättest,
der hat jetzt dieses neue Dings vorgestellt,
Dino, wo mir erst irgendwie 3-Tagespiel aufgefallen ist,
dass Dino Node rückwärts ist quasi.
Oh, richtig.
Oder eigentlich Node rückwärts wäre
Edon, aber da ist halt
mein Buchstabenkumpel ausgetäuscht.
Edon klingt auch doof. Ja, Edon hat
wahrscheinlich mal kurz drüber nachgedacht.
Aber der hat auch gemeint, es wäre eigentlich schön, wenn man das
meine, JavaScript an sich ist ja erstmal
komplett gesandboxt, aber
bei Node hast du halt die Sendbox sofort aufgemacht
und du kannst halt über die Standard Library auf das
File-System und aufs Netzwerk zugreifen.
Es wäre auch schöner, wenn du irgendwie in einem Skript
per Flag explizit sagen könntest,
du darfst jetzt Netzwerk oder du darfst jetzt
aufs File-System zugreifen.
Und dann könnte man auch ESLint so bauen,
dass es halt nichts ins Netzwerk schickt.
Das ist halt so ein inhärentes Problem
von Node.js, was er jetzt zum Beispiel
mit seinem System da
komplett lösen wollte.
Und
ich dachte eigentlich,
dieser ESLint-Hack
hätte sich explizit
auf ein
ESLint-Unterprojekt bezogen,
nämlich dieses ESLint-Scope.
Aber ich habe das gesamte Postmortem auch noch nicht gelesen.
Wir verlinken es einfach mal.
Für die Leute, die mehr Zeit zum Lesen solche Sachen haben,
als wir. Das ist bloß halt mal wieder ein klassischer
Fall von,
wenn ihr
Projekte
im
Place, ne Quatsch, wenn ihr Libraries
das ist ein klassisches Beispiel
von, das ist natürlich mal wieder ein klassisches
Beispiel von, wenn ihr Libraries
in irgendwelchen
Registries veröffentlicht, sei es
NPM, sei es
ich wo, lasst eure
Credentials nicht irgendwo rumliegen. Vielleicht
würde man da allgemein mal darüber nachdenken,
dass man die Art und Weise, wie
Credentials für diese Registries gehandhabt werden,
vielleicht ein bisschen anders aufziehen sollte.
Die gehören in den Keychain. Die haben nichts als
Plaintext-File auf der Kripte. Es ist halt bei vielen so,
dass du halt wirklich sagst, ich logge mich einmal ein
und dann kannst du halt auf deiner Konsole einfach
Push sagen. Ja, und das hat trotzdem
nicht zwingend die Voraussetzung,
dass es in der Plaintext-File liegt.
Es könnte zum einen Encrypted sein, es könnte in der Keychain liegen
auf Systemen, die sowas können.
Es gibt diverse andere Anweserfälle.
Ich habe neulich mal wieder eine Library von mir auf
Crates.io
aktualisiert und der hat,
das ging halt einfach, weil ich mich da vor einem halben
Jahr mal eingeloggt hatte, auf meinem
Terminal und eigentlich gerade beim Veröffentlichen
von Code, ich meine, GitHub bietet dir an,
dass du deine Commit-Signest.
Das machen viele
Package-Management-Systeme noch nicht
und ich hätte, würde an dieser Stelle
mich eigentlich als Veröffentlicher von sowas,
gerade wenn es was ist, was mehr als tausend Leute
benutzen,
schon freuen, wenn mir der,
wenn ich dann irgendwie so eine Tooth-Factor-Authentication-
Geschichte hätte, das wäre sinnvoll.
jemand versucht gerade dein Paket auf
npm.js oder auf
Craze.io oder auf CocoaPods
zu aktualisieren. Bist du das?
Nee, sowas gehört eigentlich
mit rein. Gerade wird sehr viele Leute nutzen.
Das müsste eigentlich, ich meine, ich werde jedes Mal, wenn ich mich
auf Arbeit in unseren Kalender einlogge
oder in unserer Wiki einlogge
gefragt, ob ich das wirklich bin.
Das könnte man bei npm eigentlich auch mal machen.
Ja, beziehungsweise es gibt ja auch diesen anderen
Ansatz von wegen
dass Autoren von
weit verbreiteten Paketen
ihre Pakete verkaufen
irgendwann under the hood und das kriegst du
gar nicht mit und dann hat es plötzlich viel anders in der Hand.
Was? Das ist schon öfter auf NPM auch ein
Problem gewesen, dass du halt
was sehr Populäres hast, dass es
gibt jemand Geld für aus und dann macht er Scheiße damit und
baut halt sowas für Code ein. Das ist halt legitim,
dass ein Update rauskommt und dann ist das
Update halt einfach malicious, was du nicht haben möchtest
als Endnutzer. Da kann sich halt auch nicht
gescheit gegen wehren. Das ist total broken by
Design. Wir sollten einfach
Computer abschaffen mal wieder.
Ja, komm,
wir machen Kaffee auf.
Ja, das gibt es ja eh schon.
Lass uns das mit dem Programmieren sein.
Das ist eh Quatsch, das ist vorbei.
Das war übrigens die letzte Folge.
Wir haben übrigens schon eine Podcast-Empfehlung vorhin hatten.
Ich habe da gleich noch eine.
Nämlich den NatPod.
Ausgesprochen eigentlich der
Not Another D&D Podcast.
Das ist eine große Klasse.
Ich bin generell jetzt aktuell dabei,
mit ein paar Freunden mal wieder eine D&D-Runde zu starten.
Und mir wurde letztens von unserem gemeinsam bekannten Julius,
der dieser Podcast empfohlen, der ist so gut.
Die spielen eine D&D-Runde zu viert mit hin und wieder mal einem Gast.
Und das ist einfach großartig.
Das ist unglaublich amüsant.
Wir haben 20 Folgen, glaube ich.
Alle so um eine Stunde oder anderthalb oder so lang,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche.
Und die Charaktere sind fantastisch.
Der eine spielt einen Halbling-Boy-Scout.
Der andere so ein Mensch, der in der Dwarfenage, also Orphanage bei Zwergen groß geworden ist.
Dort halt so ein Arschloch ist, der halt die ganze Zeit beim Sportunterricht halt,
ich kann viel schneller als ihr rennen, was seid denn ihr für luschen?
Also voll der Angeber-Mensch-Arsch da.
Und der beste Charakter ist eigentlich die Frau, die spielt eine Südstaaten-Elfe.
Oder so eine Hillbilly-Elfe eher.
Something's you missed at the crack.
Ich kann den Akzent überhaupt nicht nachmachen, das geht mir
voll ab.
Hillbilly, aber ist halt so witzig.
Also großartige Charaktere
und großartige Story.
Ein alter Schulfreund von mir nimmt zwei- bis dreimal
im Jahr an so Live-Action-Roleplay-Games
an. Das ist wie
Festival, wo irgendwie 10.000 Leute
in Kostümen rumlaufen und sich dann so
schlachtend liefern und sowas.
Da hat er mir mal Fotos von gezeigt, da habe ich mir auch gedacht,
das muss eigentlich übelst geil sein.
Bestimmt, aber ich habe, also das ist
nicht so ganz meine Welt. Vielleicht muss ich da mal irgendwo mal reinkommen,
aber D&D ist, finde ich,
schon großartig, wo man einfach den Charakter spielt.
Aber sowas würde ich auch gerne mal mitmachen, ehrlich gesagt.
Wenn man bei euch mal Gast sein kann,
dann sag mir mal Bescheid,
dann muss ich mir vorher
einen Charakter ausdecken.
Ich kann mal auch dann on the fly machen.
Wenn du generell auch nur so einen Side-Charakter für einen Abend mal dabei sein möchtest
oder auch länger, wie es dir gefällt,
das ist ja relativ schnell,
wenn du nicht so sicherlich einpflanzt.
Ich kann es ja mal probieren und dann sterbe ich beim ersten Mal.
Würde dir den Podcast an, um gerne mal reinzukommen.
der ist wirklich sehr amüsant. Wie hieß der Podcast jetzt?
Not Another D&D Podcast.
Hashtag NADDpod
ist überall, aber
wirklich ganz
große Klasse. Ich bin sehr begeistert.
Schon wirklich in der Bahn gelacht.
Lautstark.
Ist das jetzt einer deiner ersten
Stars?
Nee, wenn wir zu den Stars gehen wollen,
da habe ich zwei andere Projekte.
Und zwar fange ich gleich mal an.
Das eine ist Hugin.
Hugin ist
Rails-Anwendung, benannt nach einem der beiden
Raben von Odin, Hugin und Munin.
Vielleicht werden die auch anders ausgesprochen, ich nenne den Hugin.
Und zwar
ist die Idee dahinter, dass diese Raben
ja über die Welt fliegen tagsüber
und am Abend zu Odin
zurückkommen und ihnen berichten, was sie so gesehen haben.
Und das ist so die Idee von Hugin.
Tagline, your agents are standing by.
Du setzt jetzt so eine
Instanz von Hugin auf und dann hängst du so ein paar
Agents aneinander und lässt
mit denen irgendwelche Aktionen
ausführen und dann halt
von Dingen berichten oder was auch immer.
Also kannst du machen, was du möchtest.
Agents sind jetzt irgendwelche kleinen Module,
die entweder Input produzieren,
die auf einer Schedule laufen und irgendwelche Events produzieren.
Andere Agents können einfach nur Events processen
und manche Agents nehmen einfach Events
und schicken die an dich weiter, was auch immer.
Und ich habe da jetzt ein paar Sachen zum Beispiel laufend,
unter anderem ein Agent, der den DVB-Twitter-Feed mitliest
und einfach da eine Regex drüber liest,
von Haltestellen, die mich interessieren.
Nochmal, das ist so eine Automatisierungshilfe
unterstörst du kleine Skripte, die
immer mal wieder hier und da irgendwas nachgucken und dir
dann Notifications schicken? Prinzipiell genau
das. Nur, dass du für die meisten Sachen diese Skripte
nicht mehr in der Hand schreibst, sondern die einfach
vordefiniert von ihrer Funktionalität sind und du
aneinanderkettest, um bestimmte Sachen zu machen.
Es gibt auch einen generischen JavaScript-Agent,
den du nutzen kannst, wenn du nicht
mit dem Bereitgestellten zurechtkommst, wo du
halt wirklich alles machen kannst. Aber ich nutze
zum Beispiel einen Workflow bei mir. Sieht zwar aus,
dass ich den DVB-Twitter-Feed lesen lasse von
einem Agent, der damit Events produziert
für jeden Tweet. Ein anderer ist
ein Trigger-Agent, der diese Events
mit anhand einer Regals feststellt, ob
der weitergeleitet wird oder nicht.
Und es sind einfach die Haltestellen drin, die mich interessieren.
Und falls da eine von den Haltestellen
drin ist, dann kriege ich es als Telegram-Nachricht
diesen Tweet geschickt.
Also allgemein mal ein schöner Service, dass ich irgendwie
einen Dienst hätte, bei dem ich genau das machen könnte
und ich dann live immer...
Das ist ja quasi eine Vorauswahl für diese
TVB, Twitter...
Twitter-Feed. Ja, das wollte ich ja mal basteln
und vor allem ein bisschen schlauer noch.
bin ich immer noch nicht zurande gekommen.
Aber wenn ich dir jetzt einfach die Liste von meinen
Haltestellen, die ich immer regelmäßig verwende,
einfach zukommen lasse, kannst du mir das dann auch anrichten.
Du kannst dir auch einen eigenen Schuh hinaufsetzen.
Okay, cool.
Oder einen anderen, der
den Mensa-Feed liest, was es heute zu essen gibt
und mir ein Lort schickt, wenn es irgendwo Burritos gibt in der Mensa,
weil ich die Mensa-Burritos lecker finde.
Du kannst es natürlich cleverer machen. Also das eine Beispiel,
was schon immer dabei ist, von wegen Wetter, die die täglich holen.
Und falls es regnet, die eine Notification
schicken oder
der iTunes-Trailer RSS-Feed lesen und
die in einem Digest jeden Abend um 17 Uhr
zu schicken. Da kannst du echt viel machen.
Ich habe ein bisschen Zeit mehr reingesteckt, ein paar Sachen gebaut,
die ich sehr cool finde. Aber es geht schon fast in Richtung
Personal Assistant.
So ein bisschen, ja. Also das, was du darüber automatisieren
kannst. Aber das richtig geile Feature ist halt,
dass sie so ungewöhnlich eine echt lange
Liste von solchen Agents schon mit drin haben.
Das ist jetzt schlecht formatiert.
Aber wirklich, um alles mögliche abzudecken,
um die jetzt, keine Ahnung,
Files auf dem Filesystem zu watchen oder ein Google
Flights Agent gibt es oder generell
den iMac andockt und dir
Events für alle Mails rausfülle oder
Peaks in Events raussucht oder
es gibt sogar den Human Task Agent,
der auf Mechanical Turk,
Amazon Mechanical Turk, da halt Tasks anlegt,
die wirklich von Menschen gelöst werden, wenn du
dafür einen Anwendungsfall hast, was auch immer.
Aber du kannst darüber recht viel lösen.
Ja, zum Beispiel Pizza bestellen.
Könnte man.
Dieses Mechanical Turk Ding ist
sowieso irgendwie ein Verbrechen an der Menschlichkeit.
Ja, das ist super komisch.
Aber cool, also nicht zu verwechseln mit Hugin,
dem Panorama-Stitcher,
den ich auch noch mit unten drunter verlinke,
der eigentlich fast genauso heißt, bloß mit einem N
geschrieben wird. Kann ich gar nicht.
Kannst du gar nicht? Kann ich nicht.
Damit kannst du super geile,
dann ist das jetzt einfach
meine erste Empfehlung.
Hugin.
Ich gucke von dich einfach ab.
Ja, also dein Hugin, super geil, finde ich gut.
Mein Hugin schreibt sich mit einem N
weniger. Gibt es schon seit
Jahren,
seit zehn Jahren mindestens und ist
wahrscheinlich mittlerweile an einigen Stellen schon
redundant. Also was es ist,
ist ein Tool. Da kannst du, wenn du,
ich habe das
am Anfang vom Studium sehr
viel gemacht, als die Telefone noch nicht alle
Panorama-Fotofunktionen hatten,
habe ich mit meiner Sprügel-Flex-Kamera einfach,
wenn ich irgendwie eine schöne Szenerie
gesehen habe, habe ich einfach komplett abgetastet
und habe dann so 30 Fotos gemacht.
Und bei Huguen kannst du die einfach reinschmeißen
und der erkennt, wo die sich überlappen
und stichet die dann zusammen und
glättet dann auch die Übergänge teilweise und macht
so Helligkeitsabgleichungen und da gibt es noch eine Handvoll
mit denen du das dann richtig alles tweaken kannst.
Und das kann er dann für dich,
entweder kannst du angeben, was für eine Linse du hast,
damit er dann die Wölbung ausgleicht.
Oder er kann sie für dich auf unterschiedliche Sachen drauf projizieren,
zum Beispiel auf die Innenseite von Googeln,
wenn du es dann damit als Textur für irgendwelche 3D-Sachen nehmen möchtest.
Oder da kannst du eine Projektion so zerren,
dass du so eine Planetenansicht hast.
Wenn du ein Rundum-Panorama gemacht hast und ein Boot mitgenommen hast,
kannst du quasi so eine Mini-Planeten
daraus projizieren.
Oder wenn du bloß fünf Fotos in einer Reihe
von irgendwas gemacht hast, weil das, was
du angucken wolltest, nicht komplett in dein Objektiv
gepasst hat, dann kannst du das damit auch einfach
so nebeneinander gerade stitchen und zusammenziehen.
Da habe ich dann Fotos
von dem Haus meiner Eltern gemacht, weil ich
nicht weit genug davon weggehen konnte, um ein komplettes
Bild davon zu machen.
Genau, das kann man damit machen.
Das haben wir schon für irgendwelche
Uni-Projekte im Grundschirm verwendet.
Cool.
haben wir jetzt zwar mal Huguen gehabt, was kommt als nächstes?
Ich habe noch
R-Clone, wenn ich jetzt erst tatsächlich vor kurzem drüber gestolpert,
ist angelehnt an R-Sync,
ein Tool, was es dir erlaubt
an diverse
Cloud-Services oder
andere Seiten, die halt irgendwie
Datendumps sind, ob das jetzt
ein S3 ist oder ein FTP-Server oder
Dropbox oder
keine Ahnung, ein HTTP, ein OwnCloud,
Nextcloud, Local File System,
die Liste ist, keine Ahnung,
40 Elemente lang, grob geschätzt,
und kann halt alles andocken
und Daten dahin zünden.
Und das finde ich sehr angenehm.
Das muss ich mir nachher nochmal einrichten.
Und das hält es dann synchron?
Ich glaube schon.
Ich bin mir noch nicht hundertprozentig
auf so die Aktivdaten pusht.
Das könnte noch besser sein.
Gerade bei Nextcloud oder bei Oncloud
habe ich jetzt gerade gestern,
wollte ich meinem Vater irgendwie ein größeres Video,
was ich irgendwann mal gemacht habe, schicken.
Konnte ich ihm nicht schicken,
weil es halt zu groß war,
um es per Signal oder WhatsApp zu verschicken.
Da dachte ich, naja, ich habe es ja
in mein Nextcloud auf dem Handy so eingerichtet,
dass es alles immer hochlädt, aber das
Hochladen hat auch nicht geklappt, also musste ich es dann
nochmal hochladen, es ist dreimal gescheitert.
Es wäre eigentlich schön, wenn man
irgendwie ein Tool hätte, wo man sich wirklich absolut
sicher sein kann, dass dieser
Ordner mit dieser Cloud-Anwendung
wirklich kontinuierlich super
gesynkt ist. Also bei einem gibt es ja die
Nextcloud Desktop-Client, die sind eigentlich gar nicht mal so schlecht.
Die funktionieren ganz fürchterlich, aber
ich finde die fürchterlich von der UI,
aber die funktionieren immerhin ganz gut.
Also man sieht dem das Java Swing richtig gut an.
Ach so, ich dachte, die sind in den Ziprusmus gebaut.
Vielleicht sehen die halt auch noch aus wie Java Swing.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Jedenfalls kann das halt wirklich diverse Services.
Und ich habe gerade das Problem,
dass ich ein Google Drive habe für ein paar Unidaten,
geteilt mit ein paar Kommilitonen.
Das ist mit Google Drive.
Ja, es gibt überhaupt eine bessere Lösung,
die die anderen auch nutzen können.
Und wo man nicht irgendwie Geld für zahlen muss, damit das die anderen halt auch nutzen.
Und es gibt halt noch einen OwnCloud vom FSR, wo viele alte Daten drin liegen, was ich sehr angenehm finde.
Und jetzt habe ich ekligerweise diesen Google Drive Client bei mir auf dem System, der da eigentlich nichts zu suchen hat, wie die andere Google Software.
Der dieses Verzeichnis, was ich mit dem Nextcloud Client von der OwnCloud vom FSR ziehe, in unsere Google Drive und noch ein paar andere Daten, das kann ich mir auch mit reinlegen.
Das heißt, ich habe diese zwei Clients, die da selber Zeichnen zugreifen
und die synchron halten. Das ist ganz schrecklich.
Und ich hoffe, dass mir ArcLone das ein bisschen
abnehmen kann. Es gibt übrigens auch ein Tool,
wo ich gerade dabei bin, einfach Alternativen.
Diesmal nicht namentlich, aber
funktional. Es gibt Unison. Ich weiß nicht,
in welchem Verweisheitsgrad
das ist, aber es ist auch so ein Tool,
was es schon seit 100 Jahren gibt
und wo du sagen kannst,
hier gibt es das und hier gibt es das.
Halt das mal bitte synchron. Das funktioniert
über R-Sync oder
über SSH, es hat unterschiedliche Protokolle, die es
unterstützt. WebDub war eventuell
nicht dabei, habe ich keine Ahnung.
Und da kannst du einfach sagen,
halt mir diese zwei Ordner immer synchron oder
stelle jetzt Synchronität her. Genau, und du hast
gerade die Webseite dazu offen, die ich jetzt gerade in die
Show Notes gedumpt habe.
Und man sieht der Webseite an, dass das Projekt halt
auch 100 Jahre alt ist. Aber das hat eigentlich
relativ gut funktioniert.
Das habe ich für Sachen genommen, wo ich mir dachte,
dafür ist Git nicht wirklich gut geeignet, weil
du möchtest nicht unbedingt die History-Fundung aushaben
oder was große Dateien sind oder sowas.
Ja, cool, dann schaue ich mir das auch mal an
Ich muss bloß irgendwie
Ich finde das eklig, Google Software auf meinem System zu haben
und ich finde das eklig, wenn ich
die Client habe, die dasselbe machen
An dieser Stelle hättest du vielleicht einfach
deinem Nextcloud sagen können, synchronisiere
dich mal mit
Google Drive oder sowas
Es gibt doch auch für andere Cloud-Dienste
Backends für Nextcloud, dass du sagen kannst
Nextcloud ist eigentlich bloß
ein Frontend, nee, nee, aber du kannst sagen
dieser Ordner ist einfach ein Frontend für ein S3
oder für ein Google-Store.
Das geht auch um die. Wo sich die Leute immer
gefragt haben, warum hat
OwnCloud Verschlüsselung eingebaut?
Weil das liegt ja der
Schlüssel direkt daneben, neben den Daten.
Aber das ist halt genau dann sinnvoll,
wenn die Daten nicht auf dem gleichen OwnCloud liegen,
sondern wenn du das OwnCloud
oder NextCloud als Frontend für einen anderen
Cloud-Dienst nimmst.
Gut, cool.
Ja, eine Sache, die ich noch verlinken wollte, war diese Seite
von TC39, weil ich immer gerne
mich dafür interessiere, was als nächstes ein JavaScript
landet, weil da sind so ein paar Features, auf die alle schon
seit Jahrzehnten warten.
Das nächste, was wahrscheinlich hoffentlich kommt, ist
der Elvis-Operator.
Yay! Das wäre schön.
They call me maybe operator.
Call me maybe. Und
genau, eine Sache, die halt noch
ist, wenn ich den Tab nicht wieder einproposal,
was gerade noch offen ist,
ist
und Trim End und dann gab es glaube ich auch
Pad Start und Pad End, was quasi
Left Pad und Right Pad ist, oft Strings
eingebaut in die Sprache.
Pad Start und Pad End, genau.
Mal schauen, wann das landet.
Das Stand steht auch schon
weiter still. Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht in der nächsten Version
der Sprache landen.
Genau.
Das ist das. Und ich habe noch ein Rust Crate
gefunden, was hübsch ist.
Nämlich Type Info.
Type-Info
ist ein
Prog-Makro in Rust, wo du
deine Typen mit
Derive-Type-Info
annotieren kannst. Und dann kannst du
sie zur Runtime fragen, was sie für ein Typ
sind. Und du kriegst dann ein String raus.
Das ist ein Reflection.
So quasi Reflection, genau.
Was in Sprachen wie Java oder so standmäßig
eingebaut ist oder in Swift.
Nee.
Aber in Rust
hier, das habe ich auch so vertwittert, als ich das
das erste Mal gesehen habe, hier wäre es halt
Zero-Cost. Natürlich.
Weil, wie ist es implementiert?
Normalerweise würdest du jetzt sagen, naja, dann wird der wahrscheinlich
irgendwie die Typ-Info mit in den Typen irgendwie reinschreiben
und hast es immer mit dabei oder sowas, ist ja teuer.
Aber so wie es implementiert ist,
ist es einfach den Trade-Typ-Info für
dieses Objekt implementiert und hast halt eine
statische Implementierung, machst einen statischen Dispatch drauf
und hast eine Funktion
Punkt-Typ-Info oder sowas,
die dir dann den String statisch zurückgibt.
Und das ist natürlich, dadurch, dass
das statisch dispatchen kannst.
Es ist einigermaßen
Zero-Cost. Interessant. Also Swift
hat, by the way, keine Reflection.
Es hat Mirror-Types,
also Mirrors, mit denen du so ein bisschen Type-Info
rankommst zu Runtime, aber das ist
so gar nicht das, was die meisten Leute
verstehen, überhaupt nicht andersweise so mächtig.
Und da könnte noch ein bisschen was passieren.
Ich kann mich noch an diesen krassen
Swift-Unwrapped-Podcast
erinnern, wo sie sich
darüber unterhalten haben, dass es mittlerweile
durch geschicktes
steht alles in Typinfo
im Dings mit drin.
Wie heißt das?
Im Mangle-Typing.
Wo sie sich darüber gehalten haben, dass sie über geschicktes
Name-Mangling
die gesamten Typ-Informationen
von einem Objekt direkt in den
in das Compile hat.
Ich hasse dich.
Ein Wundgang.
Das ist doch aber eigentlich eine Form von
Reflection, oder?
Ja, wenn du da reinkommst. Also ein bisschen was geht
wie gesagt über diese Mirrors, aber
ich muss aber gestehen, ich habe mit Reflection bisher
nicht so viel am Hut gehabt in meinem Leben.
Ich brauchte das bisher nicht so häufig.
Das ist auch eher so ein Metaprogramming-Feature.
Ja klar, auf jeden Fall.
Wenn du was reinbekommst,
dann da reingucken können und darauf was machen können.
Oder wenn du eine Library baust, dass du die Namen
von dem Typen holen möchtest.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du einen Serialisierer
für irgendwas baust.
Da ist es halt super relevant.
Interessant, wenn du sagen kannst,
der Benutzer meiner Lib implementiert
was und er findet seine eigenen Typen und ich kann
aber dann irgendwie einen Finger drauf halten und sagen, wie die
heißen, damit ich das irgendwo anders hinschreiben kann. Dafür brauchst du
das dann.
Cool.
Und noch einen
Spaßstar hätte ich
und das ist
Tickies.
Tickies, was ist das?
Tickies ist
ein kleines
Tool für macOS.
und das verknüpft
deinen Tastatureinput
mit einem Soundboard
und dann kannst du so Geräusche einspielen
beim Tippen, dann macht es so blub blub blub
oder klick klick klick und dann kannst du unterschiedliche
Themes haben, die klicken deine Mac-Tastatur
endlich wirklich wie in einer alten Schreibmaschine
Ich erinnere mich an so ein Tool, was wirklich nur so
Schreibmaschinen-Sounds gemacht hat, beim Enter halt auch
beim Carriage Return halt wirklich so
Ding und dann hörst du den Schlitten zurückfahren
Wollen wir es mal, hier gibt es
ein Video, aber da weiß ich gar nicht mehr
wie es hieß
Das war auch super hacky.
Oh, God.
Das ist das Bubble Thief.
Ach, du Scheiße.
Das ist bestimmt auch mal ein bisschen nervig.
So, und jetzt
eine Cherry G80.
Das finde ich cool.
Uh, sexy.
Ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob eine alte Schreibmaschine wirklich dabei war.
Ich glaube nicht.
Welcher Basis läuft denn das?
Ha, Rastool natürlich.
Ja, das ist halt meine Filterbubble.
Sonst hätte ich das gar nicht gesehen.
Ich habe gehofft, dass es nicht irgendwie ein Node-Dings ist.
Das würdest du glaube ich nicht schaffen.
Da würdest du ja wirklich ein System ausbremsen.
Ich habe mal in irgendeinem Spiel,
was ich im Browser gebaut habe,
habe ich mal Soundeffekte eingebaut.
Und jedes Mal bin ich ein Geräusch abgespielt.
Das ist wirklich das Spiel kurz einen Tick langsamer geworden.
Oh, das stimmt.
Ich erinnere mich an ein Game Jam Projekt
von mir
und Stefan.
Die Sound-Effekte
waren auch super buggy, vor allem weil die halt auf dem
Main-Thread liefen. Ich nehme meine
Empfehlung vielleicht auch sofort wieder zurück. Ich habe jetzt auf die
Webseite geguckt, weil ich es mal installieren wollte
und die Seite heißt halt wirklich yingdev.com
und die ist größtenteils chinesisch.
Ich traue mich jetzt nicht, das zu
installieren, ehrlich gesagt. Dafür ist es Open Source
und das ist es mit Blue Cask.
Ich muss dem halt
direkt erstmal Rechte geben,
Es ist halt, wenn du genau drüber nachdenkst,
es ist ein Keylogger.
Ja klar, das ist ein Keylogger.
Also,
das ist halt ordentlich nicht logged.
Lest euch den Code nochmal durch, ich gebe hier keinerlei Garantien
für irgendwas.
Aber witzig finde ich es schon.
Doch, Typewriter ist ein Theme, was ja dabei ist.
Ich installiere es jetzt mal nicht.
Es gibt ein Issue, ist das Software safe?
Was haben sie darauf geantwortet?
einer hat drunter geschrieben
this one is open source, you can edit it if you don't trust the editor
ja wie gesagt, also ich würde
ich kann es ja mal klonen und
Gitlog drauflaufen lassen
wie viele Zeilencode das sind, ob es sich lohnen würde
das zu lesen
ein anderes Beispiel für
Safeness, hast du diese Actix
Geschichte mitbekommen?
ne
es gibt ja ein relativ neues
Web Framework in Rust, das heißt Actix
oder beziehungsweise Actix Web
Actix selber ist so ein Aktoren-Framework.
Über Aktoren haben wir vielleicht schon mal geredet.
Genau, und das ist halt nochmal ein Stück schneller als Rocket zum Beispiel.
Allerdings hat das nicht so eine schöne Metaprogramming-API wie Rocket.
Mein Wunsch darum wäre irgendwann Actix mit der API von Rocket, das wäre schön.
Aber es benutzt halt einen moderneren HTTP-Stack als Rocket.
Rocket hat noch die nicht-asynchrone Variante von Hyper.
Und Actix ist halt nochmal irgendwie eine Magnitude,
nochmal eine
10er Potenz schneller, tatsächlich.
An vielen Stellen. Hatte
allerdings ein Problem, es gibt ja diesen
Softwareentwicklungs-Lifecycle
drei Schritte.
Make it work,
make it right, make it fast.
Die hatten sich leider wohl offenbar
und das sind ein Haufen C-Entwickler gewesen, erstmal
auf make it fast konzentriert.
Und irgendwann hat einer ein Issue aufgemacht,
du Leute, ihr habt hier relativ viel unsafe
in eurem Rust-Code, nämlich irgendwie
160 Mal oder sowas.
Und ich kann euch zeigen, hier, hier
und hier habt ihr Undefined Behavior,
wenn das und das vom Benutzer reinkommt.
Und da haben sie jetzt,
das war so ein klassischer Face-Power-Moment,
so eigentlich eine schöne
Software oder eine schöne Lib, die auch performante
Web-Anwendungen damit bauen lässt. Ich hatte damit auch schon was
gebaut, das ist wirklich ganz angenehm. Und dann kommt
da draus, das ist super unsafe. Dann dagegen
jetzt Rocket Health, da habe ich da mal einen Grab
auf die Codebase gemacht und geguckt, wie viel
Unsafe-Code da drin ist.
da waren das neunmal
unsafe und da stand jedes Mal irgendwie noch so
ein zehnzeiliger Absatz-Text-
Kommentar drüber, warum
das jetzt hier unbedingt sein muss und warum das hier
wirklich kein Problem ist, kann man also alles relativ gut
nachvollziehen und bei Actix war es
an vielen Stellen Faulheit
oder sowas, also die haben wirklich unsafe an Stellen genommen
wo sie dann Variablen nicht instanzieren
mussten, die sie angelegt haben
was eventuell
ein bisschen Performance-Gain
produziert hat, aber es nicht unbedingt
Die haben es allerdings wirklich geschafft,
mit Hilfe der Community, da haben wirklich so ein paar
Kernleute gesagt, hier, wir gucken mal mit drauf
und das ist ein Problem, das ist ein Problem
und das könntet ihr eigentlich so machen.
Haben es geschafft, innerhalb von zwei bis drei Wochen
von so 160, 150
Unsafes zu
10 oder 20 runterzukommen.
Also auf eine echt managebare Menge.
Das ist eigentlich eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Aber es ist schon
krass.
Solltest schon immer mal auf deinen Code gucken, was du benutzt.
Du kannst jetzt viel über die Sicherheit von
Rascode sagen, aber wenn du dann Lips benutzt,
die extrem viel unsafe verwenden, dann
hast du halt auch nicht immer
so viel gewonnen.
Ja, ne, ist richtig.
Absolut.
Ja, du bist schon
ausgefailt?
Ne, ich habe gerade geschaut,
ob noch irgendwas fehlt an Themen.
Aber ne, ich glaube, wir sind dann für heute
durch.
Ja.
Das war Folge 020.
02020.
Wir dürfen schon Auto fahren.
Ja.
Wir dürfen bald, in 5 Folgen
dürfen wir in den USA
zusatzkostenfrei Autos mieten.
Das war ein Event.
Also dann vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit.
Das war Folge 20
von Akronomisierbar, wie schon gesagt.
Ihr findet uns wie immer auf Twitter
oder auf dem Web
akonomisier.bar
Genau.
Schreibt uns Kommentare, schreibt uns am besten
auf Twitter an, da reagieren wir am ehesten.
Über Korrekturen
freundlich gemeint,
freuen wir uns immer sehr.
Und
der nächste Podcast in eurem Feed beginnt in
3, 2,
1.